three two this is live ladies and
gentlemen and this is a very unusual
podcast we're gonna have here in a very
unusual discussion I have to my left
Michael Shermer very famous skeptic he's
been on the podcast before of course
Randall Carlson amazing gentleman who
knows far too much about terrifying
things like asteroids and graham hancock
author also fantastic human being many
times been on this podcast as well and
this all came out of a podcast that
Randall and Graham and I did recently
and Michael Shermer commented on it and
it was all essentially on the that the
hypothesis that the great extinction
that happened with the North American
land animals that happened somewhere
around the end of the Ice Age and the
end of the Ice Age the abrupt end of the
Ice Age being caused please correct me
if I [ __ ] any of this up being caused by
a comet impact Michael Shermer had some
questions about that and we said this
would be an amazing podcast to get
everybody together in a room and go over
this since then there's been some
interesting stuff that's happened well I
thought this is really fascinating that
Forbes has a mainstream article in
Forbes did a comet wipeout Ice Age
megafauna and this is actually from just
a couple of weeks ago and then there was
also this interpretation that's fairly
recent as well about one of the stone
tablets one of the stone carvings rather
on gobekli tepe and we Graham you would
probably the best to describe that yeah
that was published in Mediterranean
Mediterranean archaeology and our
qiyamah tree peer-reviewed journal by a
couple of scientists from the University
of Edinburgh and they are proposing an
interpretation of the gobekli tepe
imagery there's quite a lot of imagery
on those t-shaped pillows particularly
one pillar pillar 43 and enclosure D and
their deduction what they take from
their interpretation of course many will
disagree with them their interpretation
is that those
those images are speaking of the comet
impact they're speaking of a comet that
hit the earth roughly twelve thousand
nine hundred years before our time and
Randall this has been something that
you've been obsessed with for many many
years now we've documented and detailed
that and many in many conversations that
we've had on the podcast oh yes no I
can't say that I'm that familiar with
that article I haven't had a chance to
get into it but this idea that the comet
impact is the what what has caused the
end of the Ice Age well it's so complex
but now what we do is we throw a some
type of an impact into the mix and it
seems to fill gaps go ahead pull this
right up to you it seems to fill gaps
that were at this point still
unexplained
you know there's varying theories
between some extent of climate change
and some extent of human predation that
caused the extinction and I've always
felt like you can't blame it on one or
the other I think humans probably had a
role but only in the very final stages
of the extinction event and one of the
one of the scenarios would certainly
suggest that there were extreme climate
changes between the bob what's called
the balling allarod which was the rather
gradual warming at the very end of the
Pleistocene which was then followed by
the Younger Dryas which was the return
to fold glacial cold and in the end of
the Younger Dryas which is dated at
about eleven thousand six-hundred which
is considered now to be the boundary of
the Holocene post Younger Dryas pre
boreal it's called would be the
beginning of the Holocene and it seems
that most of the extinctions did occur
between roughly thirteen thousand and
eleven thousand six hundred years ago
although the dating has a wide spread on
it so you can't pinpoint it down to a
specific event but I've always felt like
that there had to be something we needed
to look at that triggered the extreme
climate changes that we do see at the
end of the Ice Age and into my opinion
you can't attribute that solely to
Milankovitch theories which is
basically the changing solar-terrestrial
geometries because they're too slow and
what we see at the end of the Ice Age
were very rapid climate changes and so
one of the things that I think has been
missing has been the trigger Wallis
Brecker pointed out years ago that
possibly a major flood from the draining
of Lake Agassiz caused an interruption
of the thermohaline circulation which is
the basically the circulation of the the
North Atlantic Ocean and that this might
have been what triggered the Younger
Dryas and then also contributed to the
mass extinction events but now I think
that the dating of the draining of Lake
Agassiz is too late for that and was
probably a latter event within the
overall melting phenomena that occurred
between roughly fourteen thousand six
hundred and about eleven thousand years
ago somewhere in there we have to fit
that mass extinction event and and I
definitely have thought that climate
change was the dominant factor in that
but then what triggered the climate
changed that always seemed to me to be
something that was not ever really
explained the comet impact theory is
very controversial but the evidence has
been steadily mounting now for a decade
including physical evidence right late
the core samples that show nuclear glass
scattered out throughout Asia and Europe
but roughly the same time period when
they do the core samples yes it's most
of its dating to twelve thousand eight
hundred to thirteen thousand years ago
these are called impact proxies yeah
that's prime ins melt melt glass
microspheres these kind of these kind of
things are associated with impact not
necessarily always caused by impact so
this has been part of the reason for the
controversy but it's the abundance of
all of these at a particular level which
leads a large group of scientists to
feel that we have had a comet impacting
the full assemblage of things that is
difficult to explain by processes
without invoking some type of a cosmic
event and it also corresponds with what
you believe is a period where Earth
travels through a series of comets
well this gets just to the to the ideas
of the the what would be called the
British neo catastrophists Victor Clube
and William Napier and a number of
others that have theorized that from
time to time Earth encounters the debris
from a large disintegrating comet and
there's an interesting William napier
addresses this an interesting article I
can pull up here pretty soon that
possibly around 13,000 years ago Earth
may have encountered some of the debris
from a disintegrating comet which
ultimately goes back to Fred Whipple who
is one of the godfathers of cometary
science just commit on that for a second
I mean specifically bill bill napier
Victor Clube are identifying the
remnants of this comet with the Turin
meteor stream which is familiar I think
to everybody we pass through it twice a
year we see meteorites particularly end
of October early November that debris
stream is still there it still contains
according to their argument bits of the
comet there are large objects in it like
committing enchiridion a toe and so on
for five kilometers in diameter and the
suggestion is that the meteor stream
it's got lots of small bits of dust but
it's got some larger stuff too and some
of that stuff fell out of the media
stream twelve thousand eight hundred
years ago and impacted primarily the
north american ice cap now michael when
you listen to that podcast you had some
questions you are professional skeptics
of course you're skeptical what what are
your thoughts about all this so yeah let
me pull back and give it a bigger
picture after the podcast I went and got
the book magicians are the gods and
actually I'd listened do it on audio so
it's I don't know like 16 18 hours of of
Graham reading with his wonderful
British accent which is you know for
Americans that elevates the quality of
the argument by an order of magnitude
yeah that's how they sell things and
infomercials over there and hey Graham
you're a good writer it's a very
compelling story you're a great skeptic
and and you know and so I think you know
a number of points about in general the
idea of alternative archaeology which is
really what we're talking about here
I prefer that to pseudo archeology
because that's a little bit of it it's
supposed to be a little bit of an insult
so alternative archaeology
so it's good to remember that so you
have these guys on the podcast for three
or four hours and the audience listening
thinks yeah why don't these guys get a
fair hearing I mean it's like there's
the mainstream and then there's these
guys right but but there isn't just
these guys there's hundreds of
alternative archaeological theories so
which one gets the play which one gets
attention which one doesn't and for a
mainstream archaeologists who's busy in
the field in trying to get grants and so
on they mostly just don't have the time
to sort through all these alternative
theories because this is just one and as
we'll see in the next couple hours
there's hundreds and hundreds of things
to be addressed so that's kind of what
we do so just to rattle off a few the
Lost Tribes of Israel who kind of
colonized the Americas Mormon archeology
explanation of Native Americans the
Kensington rune stones in Minnesota that
the Vikings had come here the black
Egyptian hypothesis when I was in
graduate school this book called black
Athena was published if the Egyptians
were actually black and that the you
know sort of Western white male
dominance of history had written them
out of the past so you know this was a
whole alternative history alternative
archaeology Piltdown man Thor Heyerdahl
and his hypothesis that the Polynesian
islands were colonized by South
Americans who went west went east to
west that's since been debunked but that
that's yet another one of these things
South American archaeology Olmec statues
seem to have like African features on
them so maybe Africans went directly
across to South America so there's
letting an Erich von däniken Sakurai's
Sitchin most of these graham rejects in
this book to your credit so you're a
good skeptic too but but for an outsider
to an anthropologist from Mars who steps
into this thing cold doesn't know
anything it's like well they oh they're
all alternative which is the right one
and how do we know and so what what the
way it works in science is is you know
the default position is the sceptical
position we assume your hypothesis is
not true not not just you
anybody's hypothesis it's like
that the clewd nate napier hypothesis
that was widely published it was widely
covered in mainstream scientific
journals and popular science magazines
like Scientific American and it has not
fared that well over the last decade or
so it's still around it's still debated
but that's the so you put it in them in
the mainstream through peer-reviewed
journals and then you go to conferences
and you have it out and and that's kind
of where we end up with well this is
what we think is probably true for now
and then all these other people out here
if they don't jump in and into the pool
where everybody is then there's no way
for an outsider to know whether these
alternative things have any validity or
not other than they make a compelling
case in a popular book yes but but what
did the mainstream scientists think so
and the problem is is that so a couple
of specific things like what I call
pattern isset II the tendency to find
meaningful patterns and random noise you
know the Virgin Mary on a grilled cheese
sandwich or whatever those are fun
examples but you know taking like
pictographs Peck detective glyphs and
then comparing them to constellations
like here we have some constellations on
your roof here yeah it's easy in the
mind's eye to find a pattern the
question is did those people really
think 10,000 years ago 5,000 years so
this is a field called archaea are the
director of the Griffith Observatory
here in LA this is what he does and
sometimes the pattern he thinks the
patterns mean something sometimes
they're totally random and or you take
something like the pyramids you know as
as Graham knows there's you know a
hundred theories about the pyramids and
there's the mainstream one and then
there's all these other ones and this is
why people like the director they're you
know house he just can't deal with them
all you know so just as one example I
used in my book why people leave were
things that you know one guy calculated
that if you divide the height of the
pyramid into twice the side of the base
you get the number close to pi and then
he just sort of works all these
different numbers so therefore it's
cosmically significant well Richard
Hoagland was like the best example right
I would find these patterns and Mars and
I can claim that like if you go from
this rock to half the distance and like
why would
do that like that doesn't make any sense
he would create these patterns right and
that's okay I mean all scientists look
for patterns so like to take climate
change either the earth was getting
warmer it's not either it's human-caused
or it's not there's a pattern in the
data you can see the pattern the
question is is the pattern real so this
is why there we call it we use the term
climate consensus it's not a democracy
it's not like we voted on it decided
this is the truth it's that
independently all these different
scientists working in different fields
publishing in different journals come to
the same conclusion so we call this
Concilium science or convergence of
evidence science that it's not like
these guys are meeting on the weekends
going boy we got to combat those you
know those crazy right-wingers with our
data they're independently coming to
these conclusions so that lifts our
confidence that yeah there's probably
something to their theory such that
there's now so much data converging to
this you'd have to deconstruct every one
of those independent lines so then you
have things like what I call the problem
of the residue of anomalies in any field
there are residue of anomalies we can't
explain so like UFOs for example you
apologists and media skeptic agree that
90 to 95 percent of all the UFO
sightings are explained by natural
phenomenon venus swamp gas airplanes
geese whatever they know that and so
we're really only talking about 5% like
how do you explain that one right there
in 1967 on June 3rd it yeah I don't know
no one knows that one and then from
there they billed well that's my case
right if you can't explain that then I I
have a cake no no no well that's very
different than what we're talking about
totally relevant because I think almost
all of your argument is based on this
residue of anomalies what we call a God
of the gaps argument if you scientists
can't explain you know this particular
Rock right here or that particular
petroglyph and I'm going to count that
toward my compilation of data to support
my hypothesis of a lost civilization no
one is saying that the scientists can't
explain it what would essentially
particularly Randol with this series of
images as shown
is that what you have here is something
that can be explained by rapid rapid
melting of the ice caps and Randall
stepping off you are just okay we go
ahead if you want what they do say I
mean depends do you mean by rapid you
know I mean a glacial dam that as our
geologist will tell us a moment that
that breaks that's fairly rapid mm-hmm
back in 96 it was a very popular book
called the Noah's Flood this was a
serious book by two geologists that said
it was the rapid filling up of the Black
Sea that swamped over the civilizations
living on the edges of this and that
that's where the noachian flood story
comes from okay so it was widely debated
and so on and since it hasn't fared that
well but that's fairly rapid I mean
we're talking over the course of weeks
or months or years to a geologist you
know thousands of years is rapid mm-hmm
so you know an impact by a comment
happens in a couple hours or a couple of
days or weeks versus a couple of months
or years what do we mean by rapid okay
well what are you saying then okay so
what are you saying about their theories
in particular okay so the problem I
think Graham that the deepest problem is
is much of your theory depends on
negative evidence that is I don't accept
the mainstream explanation for the
pyramids the Sphinx the Machu Picchu
whatever ELISA I talk about that let's
just talk about this specific subject
because it's going to take a long time
just together all right yeah all right
so my final point is is the
falsifiability one that is what would it
take to refute your hypothesis like for
me the answer would be like if gobekli
tepe turned out to be what you think it
might have been the place where advanced
ancient civilization once inhabited or
they used it where are the metal tools
where are the writing the the examples
of writing perhaps a decision was made
not to use metal perhaps the decision
was made that errors had taken place
that that that in reinventing
civilization we shouldn't perhaps go
down quite the same route as before
perhaps writing isn't always an advance
perhaps perhaps an oral tradition which
which records in memory which enhances
and uses the power of memory may be a
very effective way of dealing with
information we regard writing as a as an
advance and I can see lots of reasons
why it is in advance but if we put our
self into the heads of ancient peoples
maybe it wasn't I mean there's a
tradition from ancient Egypt that the
god Thoth god of wisdom was the inventor
of writing but we have we have a text in
which he is questioned by a pharaoh who
is who is saying well actually have you
really done a good thing by introducing
writing because then the words may roam
around the world without wise advice to
to put them into into context and what
will happen to memory when people who
saw so there might be a choice not to
know that all right but but then what do
you mean by advance when you say there
used to be a lost advanced civilization
before ten thousand years ago well it's
just what was here for a second because
what we know for a fact is that the
carbon dating in all the area around
gobekli tepe is somewhere around twelve
thousand years is that correct eleven
thousand six hundred years ago the
earliest they found so far but a great
deal of Gobekli Tepe is still
underground right so at least what we
know is someone built some pretty
impressive structures eleven thousand
six hundred years ago seven thousand
years before stone so when when that
story broke this is long before you came
along with your book it was
controversial in the sense that we
thought hunter-gatherers could not do
something like this because to do that
you need a large population with a
division of labor and so forth and so
what the response to archaeologists was
well I guess we were wrong about
hunter-gatherers maybe they can do more
stuff than we gave them credit for so
why is that not a reasonable hypothesis
versus they were it was actually
advanced but we mean something
completely different by advanced not
writing and metal and technology we mean
I don't know what you mean what do you
mean well I mean we have we have a body
of archaeology which goes on for decades
which is saying that megalithic sites
for example gigantea
in Malta or haggarium and Hydra
megalithic sites date to no older than
five and a half to six thousand years
old GGG
Tiye would push it close to 6000 years
old and there no older sites than that
and therefore that the megalithic site
is associated with a certain stage of
neolithic development then along comes
gobekli tepe 7,000 years older than
Stonehenge incredibly sophisticated site
very large scale I mean Klaus Schmidt
sadly he's passed away I spent three
days working the site with him he was
very generous to me he showed me a lot
he talked to me a lot and he said
basically 50 times as much as they've
pretty excavated is still is still under
the ground that there's hundreds and
hundreds of giant stone pillars that
they've identified with
ground-penetrating radar he's not even
sure if they're ever if they're ever
going to excavate them but by all
accounts we are looking if we take
what's still under the ground into
account we're looking at the largest
megalithic site that's ever been created
on earth and it pops up eleven thousand
six hundred years ago with no obvious
background to it it just comes out of
nowhere no tomatoes that's rather bad
that we know of but to me that's it
that's immediately a rather puzzling and
an interesting situation and I would be
remiss as as an author and an enquire
into these matters if I didn't take
great interest in that the sudden
appearance seven thousand years before
Stonehenge of a megalithic site that
Dwarfs Stonehenge to me that's a mystery
and it's really worth inquiring into we
love to put it into perspective that's
more than two thousand years older than
what we now consider to be the building
of the Great Pyramid of Giza in
comparison to us to then so between our
time now in 2017 and the construction
the Great Pyramid you're talking about
two thousand years earlier than that and
that is unbelievable when you're talking
about seven thousand years before what
we thought people were doing okay but
but my point was that instead of before
we go down the road of constructing a
lost civilization that was super
advanced but different from our idea of
event why not just attribute to these
fully modern hunter-gatherers who had
the same size brains we have and so on
that they were able to figure out and do
this we just underestimated their
abilities so why did Allah just tell us
for so long hum togethers couldn't do it
and we needed agricultural nations that
could generate surpluses that could pay
for the specialists
but that was so now with archaeologist
is saying well I guess we were wrong
about hunter-gatherers well they might
be wrong about hunter-gatherers or there
might be another civilization that they
had not discovered that has been on
earth lost civilizations are not such an
extraordinary idea I mean nobody knew
that the Indus Valley Civilization
existed at all until some railway work
was done around more enjoyed ro and in
1923 suddenly a whole civilization pops
up out of the woodwork that's just never
been taken into account before the 1920s
we still can't read its script you know
the idea that we that we come across
that another turn of the Spade reveals
information that causes us to reconsider
not just was it hunter-gatherers or
agriculturalists but perhaps something
bigger than this is involved or in
between there that's not that's not such
an extraordinary idea I get it that
mainstream archeology doesn't want to go
there but that's my job I don't I don't
think that that that's correct they
would be happy to go there if there's
evidence for it by what you just said
they now fully accept the Indus Valley
civilizations how did that happen if
they were dogmatically close minded I
don't say that they would dogmatically
close minded about that the evidence the
massive amount of evidence that came up
with the discovery of Mohenjo daro
harappa Dholavira and other and other
such sites is very difficult you have to
be completely stupid to say that that's
not a civilization Quebec Lee tap is a
bit more nuanced you know we have stone
we have stone circles we have some
interesting astronomical alignments the
world's first payant Lee North South
aligned building maybe no definite again
that's a pattern anything well I'm
citing clash Smith you know well that's
all right but I any of us who read back
into history 10,000 years ago what we're
thinking that they might have been
thinking that's always a dangerous for
anybody not just you all that's a good
point who's Klauss my classmate was the
original excavator of Gobekli Tepe he
was the head of the German
archaeological Institute dig at gobekli
tepe
he kindly spent three days showing me
around the site and and really nobody's
disputing the astronomical alignments of
Gobekli Tepe they weren't particularly
interesting to clash MIT but they're
there and what is the alignment like how
is it when you have a perfectly
north-south north-south aligned
structure
perfectly north/south to true north not
magnetic north then you are dealing with
astronomy by definition and there are
other alignments of the sun's true north
as established today or with the
precession of the equinoxes
okay it's the rotation axis of our
planet okay so it to this day it points
exactly the same place where it was
pointing they always place the true
north okay but back to this you know
they don't want to go sure they want to
go there they would happy be happy to go
there
case in point two weeks ago in the
journal Nature the most prestigious
scientific journal in the world there
was published an article that humans are
maybe Neanderthals lived in San Diego
area a hundred and thirty thousand years
ago this is an order of magnitude older
than the Clovis days this was the
Mastodon bones they found that so here's
an example of how okay so clearly
there's not some conspiracy to keep
alternative people or fringe or or
radical theories out it was published in
peer-reviewed the most prestigious
journal in the world there it is I'm bad
what happened well hasn't there been a
massive reaction to that and lots of
lots of scathing remarks but that's
normal that's how science works you get
you get pushed back it's you gotta have
a thick skin it's just the way you've
got to have a thick skin that's that's
for sure but maybe sometimes your skin
is so thick that you just can't sense
anything around well of course we don't
want that either so what do you think is
going on when you look at something like
gobekli tepe that's covered covered up
purposefully right
well yes deliberately buried again I
cite Klaus Schmidt he's the authority on
this he's the excavator he absolutely
adamantly insists that that site was
deliberately buried and finally covered
with a hill which is what gobekli tepe
means in the turkish language
pot-bellied hill yeah and you're talking
about something give me the perspective
of how large they believe it is
currently as a current what's excavated
at the moment is on a scale of
stonehenge what's under the ground maybe
as much as 50 times larger Jesus
but Buckley template there no one lived
there there's no tools there's no hole
you're talking but if it's buried it
should be presumably pottery there's no
pottery no writing no articles of
clothing no one lived there you're
saying nobody lived there so watch their
pottery why should pottery be in the
field but why they go along and break
some pots and stick it in the artificial
something there trash when they it's
something that would indicate it's
different a different kind of people
than what we're used to seeing in the
archaeological record in other words
it's just our nation that they poured in
it's just stones and earth itself in
other words grab for you to gain support
for your theory amongst mainstream
archaeologists they want to see positive
evidence to overturn the old theory in
other words the burden of proof is on
the person challenging the mainstream
I completely agree in every field but
isn't there some proof that the the
mainstream idea of these hunters and
gatherers never had anything in what the
theory was that would indicate these
people were capable of building
something you remotely the size of
Gobekli tend to me that's the stunning
beauty of this find it overturns our
ideas of primitive hunter-gatherer it
could not do this apparently they can it
so that's one if possible yeah that's
right so this I call this somebody else
comes the bigotry of low expectations
you know it's like we had this kind of
low expectations for these
hunter-gatherers maybe we should
jettison that idea and in my own other
field of history of religion it also
threw that off because this apparently
was a kind of a spiritual religious
that's the wrong word they would have
used actually nobody can nobody can know
that that's right so but if it was this
is that the big National Geographic
article emphasized that maybe this is
the very first religious spiritual
temple ever built because they didn't
live there so they went there for every
isn't it also possible that this is
signs that civilization was more
advanced 12,000 years ago than we
thought okay more advanced what again
what do we mean by talking about the
ability to construct an amazing
structure well okay how big was it look
at all these don't some of them are 20
feet tall yeah but some of them are
smaller with-with-with
astronomical alignments clash Schmitt
called it a center of innovation he was
intrigued by the way that agriculture
emerges around gobekli tepe at the same
time that Gobekli Tepe is created I mean
he went on record with me perhaps he's
not right but he went on record with me
as saying that was the first agriculture
these were the people who invented
agriculture now to me the notion that a
group of hunter-gatherers wake up one
morning and invents megalithic
architecture the world's largest
megalithic site and at the same moment
invent Agricole
sure stretches credulity a bit and I
think I would prefer to propose and I
have proposed that what we're looking at
is evidence of some kind of transfer of
technology that people came into that
area who had other knowledge and that
that was applied and perhaps they
mobilized the local population around
this site perhaps that's precisely why
we see agriculture developing there so
perhaps that's the skill that's being
passed on but I don't see anything
particularly ok the stonework is
spectacular but that that's not any more
advanced and a few sent a few millennium
afterwards but you're talking about
something 20 feet stone that we know
there were 100 gathers couple hundred
people can move
multi-ton stones there's no mystery in
moving the stones I start moving 20-ton
stones in Indonesia today but maybe that
culture still exists you also know that
the carving and the outside is extremely
complex is three-dimensional carving
okay but you know that means do you know
that means at Lascaux at thirty thousand
years ago has magnificent cave paintings
with three dimensions but that's
painting you know the thing hold on a
second do you know what I'm saying when
I say three-dimensional carvings like
the Venus no the carvings were on the
outside meaning they didn't carve them
into the rock they carved away the rock
around them which is pretty
sophisticated stuff for hunter-gatherers
and they're doing this on these 20-foot
tall stone columns I mean it's pretty
impressive stuff okay but they're the
assumption is that they couldn't have
figured this out we know from modern
societies where say Australian
Aborigines in one generation they go
from stone tools to fly in airplanes the
brains are quite capable of doing these
amazing planes without somebody
introducing an airplane yeah you could
you're actually making his argument form
no no it's not that much of a reach to
carve stone people have been carving
stones but the entire archeological
opinion on megalithic sites for decades
before this was precisely that it was
beyond their ability and now the
mainstream has changed okay well it's
let's sort the very least a little shift
let's pause for a moment let's pause for
a moment so for sure we all agree human
beings made this yes okay even though
they are alien so the argument
it's not whether or not aliens mated the
argument is whether or not humans made
it that were sophisticated well they're
clearly sophisticated enough to make
this incredible structure that is is
some sign of some sort of civilization
and my belief so yeah it is it's a
structure I agree with gran that we've
again undersold who these people were my
friend Jared Diamond goes to Papua New
Guinea
he talks at the opening chapter of Guns
Germs and Steel how smart these people
are that live out there in nature and
what it takes to survive well sure he
wouldn't last an hour
you know from LA he wouldn't last an
hour with his Papua New Guinean friends
out there in the in the wild because he
doesn't know how to survive and they've
been information so generation after
generation very smart okay so it's not
it's not a problem of intelligence and
it's ER okay so here's the other thing
we don't know is that there might be
lots more of these sites and where
there's there are visited one of them
Kara hunt Fe you've got you've got the
t-shaped bill is sticking out the side
of a hill in the farmers backyard I mean
I I think we're actually at the
beginning of opening up this inquiry not
at the end of it before you okay why not
just say we don't know this is a
spectacular mystery you leave it at that
right why write a book well you guys
aren't gonna fulfill it all again you
guys on the mainstream side won't
speculate and won't explore I don't
claim to be an archaeologist I'm not a
scientist I'm an author it's my job to
offer an alternative point of view and
to offer a coherent Lee argued
alternative point of view and I must say
Co Beckley Tepe strikes me as a gigantic
[ __ ] mystery and a mystery that is
worthy of exploration from a point of
view that may not satisfy you oh well
satisfy me you and your you and your
colleagues and I don't I don't I
certainly don't have to satisfy you or
them like you're opening chapter with
Schmidt I thought I really loved the the
kind of conversational style you had
with Schmidt in the book where he's
dialoguing where Schmidt goes and look
at this and then he says but but but
what wait what's that again that is like
a little bit like Columbo like wait I
have just one more quick just one more
question and you know that mystery kind
of thickens that's perfectly okay that's
great I mean that's
that's what science is all about is
uncovering mysteries that we then have
to figure out so there's always more
mysteries but that doesn't mean that's
not positive and it's in favor of a
particular theory like a lost
civilization it's just we can't explain
this
full-stop yeah we certainly can't
explain it and you can't explain it by
saying that we underestimated hunter and
gatherer well why not we know they made
it whatever you want to call them well
we know humans made it that's right we
know you haven't made but whenever you
want to climb but why do they believe
that people were only hunters and
gatherers 12,000 years ago because they
didn't have any evidence the contract
right this is evidence to the contrary
I agree so you agree that there weren't
other hunter and gatherers okay but
there's there's several stages in
between just you know 12 people living
out in the jungle by themselves sure us
you know there's like a whole bunch of
different I would say that Gobekli Tepe
is a gigantic stage well we don't okay
they didn't live there so we have to
figure out well where where were they
living and what was there so that that
has to be excavated well the only
meanwhile what you're saying is that we
shouldn't speculate at all because I
mean mainstream archeology mainstream
archaeologists speculating when saying
it's definitely was hunter-gatherers who
did this that's also a much more of a
reach okay but not okay it may they may
be more than hunter-gatherers they may
have been partially settled there's you
can have any kind of number of state
what you can't apparently have is the
possibility of a transfer of Technology
from people who are really masters of
that technology or whether when they
came in but where are these people
where's well you're dealing with
let's find their homes I don't know I
don't know that their homes matter with
their homes even survive after 12,000
years I'm not sure trapped by what
survives there's something - its trash
and tools we've got gobekli tepe it
confronts us it challenges the
mainstream model I think it's reasonable
to consider the possibility that there
was something more than just
hunter-gatherers involved here in
creating this extraordinary place that's
all I've done it seems to me that - to
say hunter-gatherers could build this
I'm not wouldn't be opposed the idea
that they're hunting and gathering but
it does certainly imply a lot
leisure time yes a lot of leisure time
well we know hundred yet sorry that's
okay looks like well again if we place
this back particularly within that that
climate zone at eleven thousand six to
twelve thousand thirteen thousand years
ago whatever it turns out to be we're
dealing with an extremely demanding and
challenging climate which which wouldn't
necessarily to my mind be conducive to
the emergence of a settled culture that
would be capable of undertaking a
project on this scale and as somebody
who's built a lot of things and moved
quite a few heavy weights in my time
I I find it the the idea sort of
perplexing to me that they would be what
I had what I would have to ask is what
is their motive what is their motive for
undertaking a project on this scale
because it's an enormous project and to
move a 20-ton block of stone is really a
challenging task to undertake today
today well without without you know you
know the infrastructure of of large
machines and so forth but to do it by
hand it would be an enormous undertaking
and and I you know to me it's like when
are they having time to hunt and gather
when you're engaged in a project of this
scale but we know hunter-gatherers have
way more free time than modern society
people do that's the one thing we've
learned is that it's a pretty good way
to make a living actually they have a
better berry diet than we have this has
been you know the Neanderthal diet right
they have a better varied diet and a lot
more free time yeah but that's a lot
less stress we knew that all along about
hunter-gatherers when we were saying
they couldn't build megalithic science
but to do it where the environment is
undergoing rapid changes to which
adaptations would be extremely
challenging and we know those changes
are going on all over the planet we know
that sea levels are right rapidly rising
over a period of a few thousand years
from from a c-stand low of about 400
feet up to the present level we also
know that that by ODIs were shifting
dramatically all over the planet the
effects of the Younger Dryas were global
pretty much that is I think the emerging
consensus now
that that both hemispheres north and
south were being affected by the climate
changes of the Younger Dryas so what
we're doing is replacing this this
phenomena this this project within this
context of these extremely challenging
times in which you know adaptation to
the environmental changes could easily
be the the all-consuming challenge of
the times I'm just finding it difficult
to imagine a disconnect to see this
disconnect between a project of this
magnitude and the motive for doing it
during a time when obviously the
environment could be posing serious
constraints upon people's ability to
function in that all right Randall we
don't even know the motives of the
Easter Islanders and no we don't raise
these huge debt but we know they did it
but as I dad become a central question
know what something had to have
motivated but let's get back to the
Beckley capita piece so we so let's just
be real clear we know there are humans
we know that it's at least 12,000 years
old and we know that the real dispute
here the real question is did these
people have structures and did they have
agriculture we know that there were
human beings they were essentially
modern human beings so were the
hunter-gatherers or did they have
struggles exactly tappy they didn't have
structures and they didn't have
agriculture Tepe they did so the fact
that they were able to build something
so monumental what kind of a leap is it
at all to think that these people could
figure out how to plant food and figure
out how to make a house well I mean
again if you look back thirty thousand
years forty thousand years to these cave
paintings these are pretty sophisticated
yes beautiful they are clearly they had
abstract reasoning they could think from
the concrete to the abstract and so on
it's not a big reach to go from that to
moving stones around I'd say there's a
big difference between painting and
engraving on the cave walls creating the
largest megalithic site that's ever been
built on earth I think there's a bit
huge difference between those two I mean
nobody would compare the construction
effort on on Stonehenge or gigantea with
with cave paintings I agree with you the
cave paintings are magnificent I've had
the privilege to visit many of the
painted case
work and as Picasso said when he came
out of Alaska we have invented nothing I
mean they were this that was that modern
human mind symbolic mind at work there
but this is another matter this is a
large-scale construction project that's
going on and it's not just a
construction person so like huts it's
hundreds and hundreds of very very large
megalithic pillars which have to be
mobilized brought to the place you know
organizing a workforce in order to do
that even that requires preparation and
time and learning and practice is not
something that you wake up one morning
it just can do overnight you think that
the paintings are more impressive than
gobekli tepe
yeah or at least comparable yes I think
that's absolutely to convey three
dimensionality on a 2d plane that that's
what because ohm is like wow that's a
crow it's like developing perspective
and to use the natural shape that's it's
but it's not create a three-dimensional
perspective look is it that's pretty
abstract comparing apples and pears it's
not a construction project no but I
don't think it's even remotely that's
what I'm saying is that it doesn't take
a huge leap of the imagination to think
these people were pretty smart they know
that they were smart we know what
they're smart just because the fact that
those construction projects were done by
who by whoever we know that they were
smart whoever built Gobekli Tepe was
clearly intelligent whoever made those
3d carvings clearly they were
intelligent but to think that someone
drawing on cave paintings is more
impressive not just 20-foot stone
columns with three-dimensional carvings
on them of a lot of animals that weren't
even native to the to the region that's
the case is that these paintings are
like say thirty forty thousand years old
to Quebec Lee Tepe so there's tens of
thousands of years to develop more that
we were very likely to find more
archaeological and yet up till now we
haven't found that we haven't we haven't
found all of that intermediate material
which see if I if I could actually see
that intermediate material between the
Upper Paleolithic cave art and gobekli
tepe if I could see the gradual
evolution and development of skills I
wouldn't need to invoke a lost
civilization the survivors of a lost
civilization who've my
those skills elsewhere to come in and
teach those skills at gobekli tepe but
it still looks to me like a transfer of
Technology unless you can show me that
evolutionary process whereby I can
understand how this group of
hunter-gatherers became equipped to
create this giant site where they
practiced where they learn the skills to
move the stones to organize the
workforce to feed and water the
workforce in a rather dry place all of
that is actually quite a logistical
challenge yep and obviously somebody met
it somehow some humans yes/no questions
did they have structures did they have
agriculture did they have some sort of a
community where they lived on the savage
location I would I would imagine so with
that would push back the time where we
thought that there was a civilization
that would push them back into a realm
of at least stead stepping out of the
hunter-gatherer stage mid as you show in
your book he did not go as far as you
that you certainly know right now buddy
you admitted it's a mystery okay what
that would be the scientific approach I
don't know what it is great mystery
let's just wait and see versus I'm gonna
postulate a lost civilization nothing
wrong with that crap it's a free country
and scientists do this all the time as
you've mentioned there's a there's a
rather humorous thing which I have to
say actually I might even ask Jamie to
pull up the the couple of images of
fingerprints of the gods that's the book
I'm best known for and when I published
fingerprints of the gods in 1995
essentially I was saying civilization is
much older and much more mysterious than
we thought and I was ridiculed for
proposing that 2013 one of the magazines
that ridiculed me New Scientist magazine
in Britain publishes as a cover story
picture of Gobekli Tepe and the headline
civilization is much older and much more
mysterious okay fair enough
and and and scientists do do this I mean
I'd followed paleoanthropology for my
whole adult life and one of the big
mysteries is how did we get a big brain
how do we get to abstract reasoning from
from say what chimps can do no one knows
the doubling of the human brain size
over period of a million years because
no one knows every couple years there's
a new book out it's
I'm a change it was the throwing arm
cooking cooking meat you know meat is
another big one a Harvard perfect meat
okay and these books come and go and
some of them have legs some of them
don't and it's just the way it goes and
then there's Terence Mckenna it's pretty
obvious it was psychedelics yeah that's
terence mckenna's but that switch the
brothers the old Julian the Julian
Jade's no bicameral mind not at all this
is David Lewis Williams who's professor
of anthropology at the University of
Witwatersrand in South Africa his
neuropsychological theory of cave art
all kudos to Terence Mckenna and food of
the gods he what a brilliant thinker
what a brilliant alternative thinking
but David Lewis Williams at the
University of Witwatersrand had been
working on this problem since 1973 and
his his argument is that the remarkable
similarities that we see in rock and
cave art all around the world are
explained that we're dealing with a
shamanistic art shamanism involves
altered states of consciousness this is
typical visions of altered states of
consciousness and it seems to have a
company to great leap forward in human
behavior and you've covered this in your
book I covered it in supernatural
natural those did you know Richard Rams
theory he's a highly regarded scientist
at Harvard so it is the meat-eating guy
then you know it's taking me writing the
protein that's what gives you the energy
to build a huge brain all right so now
this guy is starting with ten ten pluses
on his side he's Harvard and already
respected and even so his book was like
well it's probably a series of different
events and a bunch of different factors
that's right it could be a different
thing so let's get away from gobekli
tepe and ancient civilizations and let's
get back to the geological evidence
which Randall you're an expert at and
this is one of the main things that you
had a dispute with and this is one of
the reasons why we got everybody
together now what are what is your
thoughts on what Randall and Graham
proposed specifically Randall who is
much more on the geological side of
things yeah well this is why I brought
in my phone a friend right geologist so
but but by way of background after your
show I thought you know this let's just
give this a fair hearing this is what we
do so this will be our cover story and I
think the end-of-summer issue
I hope that mark diff'ent is going to be
doing some more work on the draft of his
article for you that is up online
because that article is full of [ __ ]
statements about me which had
demonstrated ly false yeah happy to I'm
happy to engage with some particular
issues well I have to put on my reading
glasses and that whatever articles are
lie this has not been published it but
it claims it claims that it's a draft of
the article that will appear in a 2017
edition of skeptic magazine so pull it
up grandma why don't we yeah let's let
Graham go over for so we'll have mark on
so here's and magician's of the Gods by
the way Michael I mean you say that
you're here to you know to respectfully
aim to get at the truth yeah there is
conjuring lost civilization from yeah
let me let me just get to the top of
this I've got it here just bear with me
a second so amongst the words in mark
defense article he's accusing me of
duping the public he's saying that I'm
public enemy number one he's accusing me
of arm waving I might I do we're by arms
pontificating well my grandfather was a
pretty administer of the church a little
interest in peer-reviewed research
claimed that no academic would debate
that's utter [ __ ] I had a debate
with Zahi Hawass he's a leading Egyptian
Egyptologist back in 2015 there was not
my fault that Zahi Hawass walked out on
that debate I can play the video if you
like a minute and a half of Zahi Hawass
lambasted me and then walking out and
refusing to debate further so it's
[ __ ] to say I don't debate or I'm
not willing to debate and finally he
says that I'm conning a hellacious
number of people into buying his books
now how can we get any dialog going when
somebody begins like that okay then
would you like some further bear with me
because I just have to scroll down and I
don't have a mouse I don't have a mouse
so Hancock and Carlson claim to several
times that a cadet no academic would
debate them not true I'm accused of
doing an about-face
since since fingerprints of the guards
are my I mean are my views not allowed
to evolve with with new evidence is that
somehow crime on my part let me just
finish then a cheap shot you know he
cites his Kamara
and and and and accuses me of not real
not having the scientific knowledge to
issue deal with issues of gravitation
now it's true that hey Suz Kamara who is
a descendant of the Incas who has worked
70 years on the megaliths of
sacsayhuamán whose father before him are
Fredo Gemara worked 70 is true that he's
got a way out theory about gravitation
thing is I state in my book that it's a
way out theory what I go on to say
quoted in the attack is that however
this isn't the part of his theory I'm
interested in where I feel he is solidly
persuasive is in his observations of the
anomalous character of the monuments of
the add these etc et-cetera default
doesn't cite that he just presents me as
buying what his sous Gemara says I mean
if that's a standard that you're gonna
have in skeptic magazine you have a
serious problem and then go back Lee
Tepe he contends that Gobekli Tepe is
too advanced to have been completed by
hunter-gatherers and must have been
constructed by a more advanced
civilization well no that's not what I
say I say it was constructed by
hunter-gatherers
but that they were advised and supported
by people who had knowledge of this kind
of work beforehand getting a war I think
it's very different I'm not saying it
was constructed by I'm saying that a
group of people settled amongst
hunter-gatherers and transferred some
skills for them he says that he quotes
me Hancock makes the following stunning
claim quote our ancestors are being
initiated into the secrets of metals and
how to make swords and knives I do not
make that claim I'm reporting that this
claim is made in the Book of Enoch that
is not my claim then what else you know
I think that the explanation well I'm
being misrepresented by your author here
if he wants to represent me if he
accuses me of cherry-picking he
shouldn't here's a beautiful one he
cites Klaus Schmidt on the on
on the character schmidt makes a salient
point almost as if he anticipated
Hancock's book quote fabulous or
mythical creature creatures such as
centers or the Sphinx winged Bulls or
horses do not yet occur in the
iconography and therefore in the
mythology of prehistoric times they must
be recognized as creations of the high
cultures which arose later well [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you've just been
talking about the painted caves go to
Chauvet Cave you'll see a lion man holy
science start a lion man carved out of
carved out of mammoth ivory go to go to
shove a bison man straddling lion woman
her right arm is transferring is
transforming into a into the head of a
lion
so certainly these mythical creatures
did exist in the Upper Paleolithic and
it's rubbish to say that they didn't I
mean how can I go on the teapot oh yeah
okay so he's he's taking issue with me
because I suggest that the vulture on
pillar 43 and enclosure D is
representing the tea teapot asterism of
the constellation of Sagittarius and he
goes and gives us little things of Uncle
Sam and some other thing that he shows
if you know anybody can impose any image
on on anything well it's not my fault
that a couple of academics who didn't
even talk to me and had nothing
whatsoever to do to me have published a
major study in the I quoted again the
Mediterranean archaeology and our
qiyamah tree a peer-reviewed journal
where they make precisely that
identification so at least I'm not alone
at least there are there are
peer-reviewed credential scholars who
also agree that that figure is
representing the teapot asterism within
the constellation of Sagittarius no
reference to that shops opinions we're
supposed to not go into the minutiae eye
because they've already been dismissed
by a study by Larissa sand mafia do far
from it that study doesn't dismiss shock
at all none of that study was done on
the body of the Sphinx itself it was
done in the valley and the Sphinx
temples and by the way the dates are
extremely troubling some of them could
push it as far as 3600 BC that the work
was done or as early in some cases as
1000 BC I don't think that study proves
anything and and and so I'm supposed to
clarify what you do believe in so that
we don't misrepresent you
so you don't think that the lost
civilization instructed them on the use
of metals I don't know I don't see
evidence for that correctly tell me
would you put that in the book then I
didn't put it in the book I was quoting
the Book of Enoch it's a huge passage on
them on the Book of Enoch it's made not
me who's saying that is the Book of
Enoch the same I understand but but why
all I require your diff'ent to do is to
state that Hancock is citing the Book of
Enoch he didn't do that
disingenuous is that the polite word you
guys use but more than bears in genuis
it's it's a character so what the
question is is why would what's the
context of including that in your book I
forget well the God the context is that
actually I was I was criticizing
zecharia sitchin that's primarily what I
would say you don't think that a lot of
civilization instructed the people who
built Gobekli Tepe on the use of metals
and tools I see no evidence for that
I see gobekli tepe I can't I can't go
say they instructed them on the use of
metals and tools unless I can find
everything else Oh what did they do
we don't know generated agriculture they
created a center of excellence around
which I don't agree not the day who
built Gobekli Tepe the lost civilization
that advised them that you think
happened yeah what did they do if they
they've come through a cataclysm they're
survivors pew in number this is my
scenario you don't have to accept it I'm
sure you don't they settle amongst take
refuge amongst hunter-gatherers I mean I
don't know you're probably quite have
some survival skills I don't have many I
mean if if we would have a comet impact
in the world today which were to take
out all the underpinnings of modern
civilization I might go settle with
hunter-gatherers because they're the
people who know best how to gathers but
I might be able to transfer some of my
knowledge to them I might be able I
might have something that I could
transfer to them and I might have very
strong reasons why I might not choose to
transfer all of it but it's Owen in
other words perhaps this is what
happened okay maybe but how is that
different from Zecharia Sitchin's that
well the aliens advised it well I think
it's massively different especially
since Zechariah Sitchin has his aliens
arriving here in 1970s NASA Technol
weirdly he wrote his book in the 1970s I
mean I don't I I I don't go there I
don't make that I don't make that
suggestion I'm simply saying perhaps
there's been a forgotten episode in
human history
perhaps it's fingerprints are present at
a number of sites around the world but
perhaps the extremely defensive arrogant
and patronizing attitude of mainstream
academia is stopping us from considering
that possibility and therefore I
campaign to get that possibility
considered and I try to do so with as
louder voice as possible well you're
doing it it doesn't disturb you that you
mean you run skeptic magazine and
someone publishes something like that it
mean that goes against the whole idea of
critical thinking I mean it's it's
misrepresenting his quotes
misrepresenting his perspective his
point of view it's it's really
disingenuous this is one reason we're
doing this so we could get his but why
would anybody write something like that
and why would you guys publish something
like that without checking the facts we
are this was not supposed to be posted
online person who will do that a useful
contributor to your side of the debate
well one of the reasons we're here is to
get your point of view
exactly right all right so you're saying
that there's no evidence that any lost
civilization exists only that no I'm not
saying that I'll say fingerprints of
their their influence on later peoples
we do know existed I'm saying there are
physical objects I say gobekli tepe is
one of them I say the Sphinx is another
but see this is that argument from
either ignorance or personal incredulity
I don't accept the mainstream or I can't
think of how this pyramids could have
been built therefore it was built by
somebody else through some other
technology that's not what I'm saying
just post dating it just thinks is older
I do go with Robert Chuck's argument on
the geology I'm also very interested in
the astronomy of the site and again I
have slides that I could show on this if
we have if we have time you might want
to get into ed crops
criticism of the Orion correlation and
why he says it's up to upside-down I can
talk to you about that you know we do I
mean I I know it corrupts argument about
that and that was from the 90s I think
what's your thoughts on Robert Chuck's
conclusion I don't
that's not something I know any much
about laughter it's a huge factor knows
about show and he rejects him on the
basis of that paper yeah and that paper
really doesn't date the Sphinx it works
with dating of large blocks in the
valley and the Sphinx temples there's
not a single sample taken from this week
all right then who dated it who dated it
Liberty Sabathia and then why why do
mainstream archaeologists not accept the
older date for the Sphinx and in the
answer is because they have a whole
bunch of other evidence that points to
the date that they think the answer is
very to your question is very simple
mark Lehner and Zahi Hawass put it on
record back in 1992 when John Anthony
West and Robert Schoch first presented
the rainfall erosion evidence on the
Sphinx and what later and Hawass said is
the Sphinx can't possibly be 12,000 plus
years old because there was no other
culture anywhere in the world that was
capable of creating large-scale
monumental architecture like this show
me one other structure that's capable of
doing that well they could say that in
1992 Michael but they can't say it in
2017 not since gobekli tepe
if you don't mind Graham could you
please four people so this could be a
standalone thing people could understand
what is the argument about the Sphinx
the enclosure the Sphinx and dr. Robert
Schoch from Boston University who's a
geologist what was his conclusion what
Jacques is saying is that the Sphinx and
the trench out of which the Sphinx is
cut bears the unmistakable evidence of
precipitation induced weathering
weathering caused by exposure to a
substantial period of heavy rainfall and
that is particularly pointed out in the
vertical fissures in the trench they see
the Sphinx itself has been subject to so
much restoration over so many years that
it's difficult for people to even see
the core body of the Sphinx today but
it's these you can see the vertical
fissures even down at the back of there
that is that is what Jacques counts as
rainfall precipitation induced
weathering heavy rainfall which is
selectively removing the softer layers
and leaving the harder layers in place
and the problem is we don't have that
rainfall in Giza in Egypt four and a
half thousand years ago you have to go
back much earlier to get that rainfall
that's the suggestion so that's the
suggestion by Robert Schoch
independently yes if your conclusion is
totally independent
Jacques disagrees with me on many things
isn't as a matter of fact and and I
disagree with him on many things but I
think he's on the money on this so that
alone would set back at least that one I
mean it's pretty much established that
the Great Pyramid of Giza was
constructed about 2,500 BC right
absolutely no doubt that a huge project
went on at Giza around 2500 BC so your
argument there not that the whole thing
was that much older was that parts of it
seemed to have been from an earlier
civilization or at least that
civilization far far earlier than I was
I would say that the ground plan what we
have at Giza the basic layout of the
site was established in what the ancient
Egyptians called Zep tepi the first time
astronomically and geologically I and my
colleagues suggest that the first time
can be dated to the period of about
twelve and a half to thirteen thousand
years ago that that that was when the
site was laid out because there's
intriguing astronomical alignments of
the great pyramids to the belt of Orion
I know ed Krupp has a completely
opposite view on this and of the Great
Sphinx to the constellation of Leo
rising due east housing the Sun on the
equinox the astrological age of Leo
again I have slides I can and that was
aligned with the geological evidence
that Robert Schoch comital eyes with the
geological evidence the age of Leo
pretty much exactly spans the Younger
Dryas as a matter of fact and so the
only argument against that at the time
was that there were no other structures
like that from 12,000 years correct and
then Krupp said that the the Orion
correlation wasn't real because it was
upside down I'm a diggin into that now
well first that's not the only argument
it's that okay if the Sphinx is built or
the layout for the whole thing is built
in it's a ten eleven thousand years ago
and then and then the pyramids are built
you know 2500 BC what happened in
between where all the people the trash
the places where they live well there's
a bunch of different styles of dated in
between I would propose Michael
something like a monastery which has a
relatively small archaeological
footprint is on the site I mean the idea
of information knowledge and traditions
lasting 4,000
of years within a religious system
shouldn't be too absurd to us I mean
Judaism is dealing with ideas that are
already best part of 4000 years old if
we go back to Ora the child ease and so
on and so forth so that's all I'm
suggesting really that the idea is
preserved maintain that the survivor
survived on the site but on something
like a monastery which is which has got
a very small archaeological footprint it
is not high perhaps again one can only
speculate and I think there's a lot of
speculation on the archaeological side -
one can only speculate perhaps having
gone through a cataclysm perhaps they
felt to blame for this wrongly or
rightly I mean there are many many
traditions in which humanity's behavior
is implicated in the Cataclysm that
takes place and perhaps they didn't want
to switch civilization on completely
right there perhaps they perhaps they
waited passed down the knowledge through
initiates enough was there to create a
mystery because it's undoubtedly a
mystery that the construction of the
great pyramids
the first huge pyramids in Egypt
preceded only really by the Zozo pyramid
at saqqara that the construction of the
great pyramids is vastly superior to the
construction of the pyramids of the 5th
and 6th dynasty that follow it and
that's a little bit counterintuitive
that we have this collapse in skills one
would have expected it to got better so
it sounds like the work on the pyramid
started already with a level of
knowledge in half yes but ok so here's
here's I would think about that there's
a lot of perhaps seeing and maybe
speaking yes well so you have a bunch of
Egyptologists and archaeologists who
have been working on this site for
centuries this is one of the most you
know ancient mysteries and so on and and
so say let's say there's like 20 lines
of evidence that point to built roughly
around this time period here and then
you come on and say okay but there's
this one anomaly of the rain thing that
in that there was only rain at this time
now there's a huge gap you have one
anomaly or line of evidence here and
like 20 here we're talking about
different structures so there's not a
lot of evidence that points to the
Sphinx being from a particular time
period well he's saying like 12,000
right I'm saying the rainfall evidence
suggests that alignment that its
alignment with the constellation of Leo
housing the Sun right dawn on the spring
equinox it's an equinoctial marker
nobody would dispute that
would dispute that the ancient Egypt
leaders I've stood on the back of the
Sphinx at dawn on the spring equinox and
believe me again I could show a picture
its head lines up perfectly with the
Rising Sun but no I don't think anybody
even Krupp is disputing that it's a neck
for notional market now here's the thing
you're an ancient Egyptian you're
building an equinox your marker in 2500
BC do you know what constellation is
housing the Sun in 2500 BC I haven't run
the little program well it's the
constellation of Taurus so so logically
if you're creating an equity option and
the ancient Egyptians were not shy about
making images of bulls
plenty of them if you're making an
equinoctial marker in 2500 BC we should
created in the form of a bull not in the
form of a lion you know that's the
that's the puzzling issue and yet we do
have a time when a lion constellation
housed the Sun at dawn on the spring
equinox and that is the period of the
Younger Dryas okay I'd say that's a
pretty big leap well I know you say that
and your colleagues also and so now and
then we have a gap of about five or six
thousand years where there's nothing
back to several articles that were
published in the 80s and 90s this one is
from from nature early 80s late
quaternary history of the Nile and what
it's discussing is the evidence that
there was a major shift in the in the
hydraulic regime of the Nile River it
says between 20,000 and 12,000 years
before present when Timberline into
headwaters was lower vegetation cover
more open than today the Nile was a
highly seasonal braided river which
brought mixed coarse and fine sediments
down to Egypt and Sudan this cold dry
interval had entered ended by 12,500
years before present when overflow from
Lake Victoria and higher rainfall in
Ethiopia sent extraordinary floods down
the male main Nile and those floods have
been documented to have been a hundred
and twenty feet above the modern flood
plain of the Nile any civilization or
whatever you want to call it living
along the Nile River at that time would
have had to abandon whatever they were
doing there in there in this regime does
intensify
hydraulic regime and it says it goes on
to say it marked a revolutionary change
to continuous flow with a superimposed
flood peak so what happened is that
there was a major environmental change
that occurred right there around twelve
thousand to twelve thousand five hundred
years the dating could be adjusted
somewhat since the early eighties but
the point is made is that because of a
major hydrological change major of
educational cover change major
environmental change this would have
caused also imposed changes upon
whatever culture was existing there or
living there at the time now what we
have is in the aftermath of that event
we have basically the emergence of
desert which now would require serious
adaptation it's very likely to that
these events could have also decimated
the population at the time leaving
basically no workforce and then over a
period of two or three or four thousand
years you find that that there's enough
of a recovery that these kind of
monumental structures can be renewed but
it's clear from this and a lot of other
studies studies in the eastern
Mediterranean showing that there are SAP
rappel layers which is caused which is
basically material that has been washed
in from the continental surface that has
not oxidized it has essentially become
rotten and carried in organic material
carried in off of the continents by this
enhanced regime of water flow actually
forcing so much water that there was a
freshwater lid on the eastern
Mediterranean that caused a cessation in
the the circulation between the upper
waters and the lower waters reducing the
amount of oxygen brought down to the to
the lower waters and so you had these
layers of mud that formed on the bottom
of the Mediterranean that show this
massive influx of fresh water flowing
off of out of the Nile and off of the
the Egyptian continent at this same time
so clearly the evidence shows that there
were made
your climatic changes that occurred
around this time it is not so
speculative to to imagine that whoever
whatever and we don't have to invoke any
kind of a super advanced civilization
but whatever cultures were there that
were perhaps capable of carving blocks
of stone transporting blocks of stone as
they were at gobekli tepe during this
time range would have been that their
that their activity would have been
interrupted to the extent that it might
have taken millennia to recover to get
to get the labor force necessary to
undertake major monumental programs on
the Giza Plateau so I think that that
the if we assume this gradualist Excel
yeah that's a fair question to ask were
what happened in that interval but if
there is a major climatic downturn and a
major disruption of the the several
patterns of whatever culture was already
there then you know now we might have an
explanation why there would be a gap
especially if these events caused a
bottleneck in the population of the area
of course this is all speculative but it
is not speculative to say that there is
multiple lines of evidence suggesting
these major even cataclysmic changes
that engulfed that part of the world
during that era so that could that could
provide an explanation of why there is a
gap there
makes no sense well it does it because
does it not only if you have to have the
Sphinx in conjunction with 12,000 years
ago in the lost civilization if you just
say the rain water erosion on the Sphinx
it is not an explanation for the Aged
and that the traditional accepted age is
what we think it is then there's no gap
to fill yeah so really all we're talking
about is we have again lots of evidence
here one anomaly here I really want the
anomaly thing to stick so I got
explained the gap the gap is explained
by environmental changes but what has
the when is the lots of evidence other
than a lot of assumptions there's a lot
of maybes it's all I mean actually can
you cite me a single contemporary
inscription from the date that the
Sphinx is supposed to have been made
that refers to this
I'm sorry can you cite a single
contemporary inscription contemporary
probably should be contemporary to the
date that Egyptologists ascribed to the
Sphinx in other words the reign of qu
can you cite me a single inscription
that talks about the Sphinx being built
this is I don't study this area I don't
know okay well you can't because there
is no such description okay
well so well one would have thought they
would well maybe it's a giant project
it's 270 feet long is 70 feet high it's
carved out of solid rock nothing but you
know references at all in the Old
Kingdom you actually have to come down
to the New Kingdom to get references to
the Sphinx and inscriptions but you've
already said that the pyramids were
built at the time we think they were
built not thousands I would say that a
great deal of work was done on the
pyramids at the time of 2500 BC I think
the ground plan was laid out and we have
like the Step Pyramid which is cruder
and not as well designed as the other
pyramids that's it that's a transitional
stage at that time often argued to be a
transitional stage have you've been to
the Step Pyramid I'm sure now right and
and been to Keys it though no I've never
been to Giza oh dear well well they do
make a very different impact
I mean I've climbed the Great Pyramid
five times I mean you're dealing with
something orders of magnitude different
in terms of what's required I mean this
thing weighs six million but it's 481
feet high it consists of two and a half
million individual blocks of stone it's
a line to true north within three
sixtieths
of a single degree I mean to compare
that to Zoser
is really not a valid comparison at all
what's more interesting to me is the
radical decline that takes place in
pyramid building skills in the fifth and
sixth dynasty go to UNESCO to Pepi go to
Teti at saqqara these are a shambles you
can hardly even recognize them as a
pyramid what happened to all that
knowledge that's invested in the Great
Pyramid why does Egypt devolve so
rapidly why how do we explain this
Christine amazing work that's done on
the Great Pyramid unless there's a
legacy of knowledge being attached to it
okay so every archaeologist each Egypt
Egyptian archeologist and Egyptian all
knows everything you just said they did
and they don't accept any of your
arguments why no that's why I'm needed
because somebody's got a counter is it
just that they're close-minded and they
follow sake of us and they never think
for themselves you want to see it
where's mine
I'll play your one and a half minute
video I'm sorry a wash refused any
debate with me but but but all of them
every one of the Egyptologists and
archaeologists over the last two
centuries and so on they know they're
all dogmatically closed-minded and they
can't see the arguments that clear as
you or is it they're not convinced by
your argument they're not convinced by
my argument they genuinely and
absolutely believe that their argument
is right the notion that I'm proposing
is apparently so preposterous to them
that it isn't even worthy of
consideration but it is worthy of
insults and attacks on me on my
integrity on my decency as a human being
on my honesty all of those things get
attacked
you know because mainstream that's fine
I'm ready for that and that by the way I
know that archeologists academics
constantly attack each other all the
time I used to take this stuff
personally but then I want to see what
they do to each other
the ravaging attack dogs yeah I let
loose on on any new idea
I sometimes wish scientists would would
actually look for what's good in the new
idea rather than what's bad but I get
why they do that but in other words a
gret that some young graduate student
working in that area could make a name
for himself by overturning you know my
son was a young graduate student at the
University of Cardiff studying
Egyptology he got marked down in his
degree because he proposed the
possibility that the pyramids and the
Sphinx might be or might have older
origins he was impressed by my work it
did him a lot of harm in his degree and
if all this was true then a very few of
my point would come down to my point
which is if you go against the
mainstream view your career does not
progress as in Egypt I disagree I mean
how an example how is it that we know
anything that we know about Egypt no
example from Egyptology if somebody
who's gone against the mainstream view
and being lauded for so doing well look
we don't believe everything about it
that we believe two centuries ago and
it's a Napoleon's time right how did all
that knowledge come about how did all
the change and that science nobody
begins with seanpauley on and the
deciphering of the Rosetta Stone all
right how was he able to do that against
the mainstream
there was no mainstream all right he was
explains the mainstream has taken time
to form and it's very solid now I mean
Scientologists all sing from the same
hymn book you'll find very little
disagreement about the nation in every
field but somehow or another Einstein
managed to make an impact because he
turned out to be right well
Einstein and I don't know if I'm right
but I'm gonna continue to oppose that
mainstream somebody has that's a valid
comparison Einstein and archeology would
take paleoanthropology I mean it's a
completely different feel now than a
century ago
how did that happen if no one ever
accepts new ideas they do it happens all
the time
well they're being forced to accept
exactly tepi and that's a new idea that
you know where you were talking about
things taking a long time and what seems
like a long time to us is really a blink
of the eye and in terms of archaeology
we're in the middle of that we're
essentially in the middle of that with
things like gobekli tepe with forbes
publishing an article about the Younger
Dryas possibly being impacted by comets
and that being one of the causes of a
mass extinction right and when these are
all mainstream ideas and I when Alvarez
proposed the impact hypothesis for the
demise of the dinosaurs in 1980 it was
ridiculed and but he turned out to be
right and then that became accepted
right it takes time about what was the
keep telling people are challenging
there's not the key turning point the
finding of the crater that's what that's
what made the difference yeah so we're
not argue with it I get where's your
crater well this is where perhaps we
need to bring in our phone a friend you
know
Malcolm lecompt one of the one of the
Younger Dryas impact scientists I mean
the the point the point being made is
the following firstly that the primary
impacts were on ice that they may have
been as many as for impacts that they
were on the North American ice cap some
craters have been suggested for example
very deep holes in the Great Lakes other
craters have been and will be looked at
by the team in the in the coming months
whether it includes the Corozal crater
they could cook or Bechet terrain and so
on and so forth there are candidates
that the crater has not been found yet
but I would be surprised if a crater was
easy to find when you know the impact is
on two mile-deep Ison
you know one of the biggest strewn
fields in the world which is the
Australian strewn tektites true--and
field there's no crater associated with
that but everybody accepts the impact
proxies there's enough of them to
justify that and that's what's going on
around this impact hypothesis oh and a
related question of that is and not the
lost civilizations of the demise of
humans but the megafauna extinction of
North American mammals so this has been
long debated before the impact
hypothesis was proposed and the
competing hypotheses were
overhunting humans just hunted them to
the point where not every last one to
the point where the population numbers
get too low and these species can't
survive or climate change or both the
climate change weaken the populations
then the humans came over and over
hunted them alright so and then the
impact hypothesis is proposed okay so
this was debated and it didn't fare that
well because there were a lot of mammals
and other species that didn't go extinct
that you would expect from a massive
impact like that it would have wiped out
why why the selected species the kinds
of species that humans would hunt are
the ones that went extinct whereas these
others didn't hunt the largest I there's
no evidence that human humans hunted the
Predators there is evidence that they
hunted woolly mammoths but it's very
sparse I mean you have no more than a
dozen sites that show association
between human hunting and mammoths and a
lot of those like the Lubbock Lakes site
is now being questioned what was
presumably we've previously interpreted
as being butchering marks on on the the
mammoth remains there are now being
reinterpreted as is possibly natural
marks on the on the mammoth bones but
it's a big stretch to go from oK we've
got a dozen sites where we have mammoth
remains and along with those mammoth
remains we find a few Clovis spear
points in two or three cases we actually
find or they have found spear points
embedded within the mammoth like in the
RIP rib cage but it's a very large
stretch to go from there to say that 10
or 12 million Willy mammoths or four
species of mammoths on four continents
were wiped out by paleo-indian hunters
probably in bands of no more than two or
three dozen you ever been to a head
smashed in buffalo sight yes but but but
that's a good example because no where
did that go anywhere close to
exterminating the species of American
bison but that each site has its own
particular explanation could be hunting
could be a massive flood earthquake
whatever there'll be a massive flood yes
exactly I think they're known I would be
in complete agreement it mean by massive
there's a global versus you know local
so for example there's 52 mammalian
and genera went extinct in South America
why would they go extinct in South
America about the time that humans were
moving down there hunting the Younger
Dryas impact hypothesis includes South
America there are impacts there there
does in you know again the dating of the
the migration of humans into South
America is controversial at this point
you know there is evidence that humans
were there long before you know Paul
Martin's idea of of blitzkrieg requires
that the animals be so stupid that they
couldn't they had no adaptive
capabilities to the appearance of a new
predatory species but whoa what is being
demonstrated from examining the life
ways of the Paleo Indian peoples is that
they had very diversified diets and they
were hunter-gatherers now why would they
be choosing the largest most dangerous
animals to hunt when they had such a
proliferation of other smaller animals
we know that they were foraging we know
that they were eating seafood there was
and and fishing because all of this is
being found in the in the camps and then
it certainly doesn't explain the
extermination of you know the the cave
bears the short-faced bears the camel
ops the the giant beavers the giant
armadillos the American Pleistocene lion
the the the the ground sloths that were
the size of giraffes four species of
Provos aliens meaning mammoths extinct
on four continents and to me like wait a
second we don't we cannot we cannot
invoke a modern example just to say well
here is a Mallory well that's
controversial also I mean they drove the
battle birds extinct and passed eagle
that in people with addle addle is
killing off all the saber-tooth Tigers
and here's another answer to one of your
questions you were saying like why would
some of the animals be alive well we
know that the the asteroid that killed
the dinosaurs 65 million years ago
didn't kill everything right right that
is a massive impact far bigger than
anything we're talking about and many
many animals survived that so we don't
know why things survived and wide
don't it could be proximity to the
impact it could be that their food
source wasn't removed it could be that
their predators were wiped out and they
managed to survive I mean there's a lot
of animals that are still that are alive
today in this continent like for
instance a pronghorn antelope pronghorn
antelope Dan Flores is a wildlife
historian wrote an amazing book on it
and we what he was talking about the
American savanna during you know like
15,000 plus years ago there was all
sorts of crazy animals millions of years
ago that were like cheetahs that were
running down animals at extreme speeds
which is the reason why pronghorn
antelope
can run so much faster than any of their
current predators something much faster
than them was killing them and that was
wiped out but they managed to make it
one of the reasons why they probably
managed to make it is because they're
predators were wiped out it's not even
the point Michael if it's overkill it's
it's intriguing that the overkill occurs
you know precisely in the Younger Dryas
window because I think you'd agree that
now the whole story of the peopling of
them of the Americas is pretty much up
for grabs I mean Clovis first was the
dominant model for a very long time and
under that model we're to envisage these
Clovis hunters coming in across the
Bering Land Bridge going down the
ice-free corridor and then in like 800
years with their sophisticated fluted
points they wipe out all the mammoths in
in North America but now we know that
humans have been coexisting and
butchering mammoths coexisting with
mammoths for thousands of years before
that possibly tens of thousands of years
before that I mean from evidence in
Siberia I I don't only mean from
evidence in Siberia I mean I can cite
you from from nature magazine just
recently a huge huge number that I don't
think the Yukon is in Siberia is it no
new ponds in North America
Jack sank Mars you know the excavator of
the Bluefish caves in the Yukon back in
the 1970s where proposed was proposing
that human beings had been in Americas
at least 24,000 years ago his reputation
was utterly destroyed his research
funding was withdrawn he was given no
access to grants he wasn't able to do
his work he was heavily penalized and
punished by the community and now just a
few weeks ago we have the Smithsonian
coming out and saying sorry we got it
wrong Jack saint-mars was right all
along
Tom Dilla hair you know with his work in
Monteverde the [ __ ] that he had to take
I think we're we're in a very
interesting time the peopling of the
Americas is is really a paradigm that
has absolutely been overthrown the
notion of well you disagree with
Smithsonian then which is fine I'll do
the Mesa Verde
you know it's an I so again it's an
anomaly it's an isolated sight what do
you where are all the sites between
Clovis and Monteverde you wanna see
Clovis was still first for thousands and
thousands of years come on Mikey still
first where are all the people between
Clovis and my problem not my problem
they're in Monte Verde and they're there
in North America what's more likely than
Tracy South American Indians and not in
North America it's like it's like the
nature paper by maybe people cross the
ocean that that there were Neanderthals
or humans in San Diego 130,000 years ago
okay but when you look at that okay so
they have mammoth bones it looks like
they might have been broken in the
length you know okay and the tools but
they're not okay the tool we're kind of
changing subjects here though oh no no
it's going to try to quibble the
evidence of nearly a human presence
that's right you try to quibble it
well not quibble well you couldn't like
it you're quibbling it I think very
specifically that's opposing what he
just said the reason archaeologists
don't accept earlier than Clovis a early
13 is massively it's massively accepted
say Mesa Verde for in image why don't
they accept Mesa Verde they do accept
Mesa Verde as it is accepted like what
you sure about this is why 24,000 years
15 plus possibly possibly significantly
yeah significantly 15 is kind of the
outside of the window that humans came
across the Bering Strait that's possible
not 24,000 clevis first not a hundred
and thirty thousand years ago now if it
turns out that that nature paper is
right and that's confirmed then that
does overturn the mainstream theory for
sure but why would you this is not like
your field of study why would you argue
against the nature listen okay I'll just
give you let's quote this Missoni ask
profession Smithsonian slide number five
today decades later the Clovis first
model has collapsed
okay based on dozens of new studies we
now know that pre-clovis people's
slaughtered mastodons in Washington
State dined on desert parsley in Oregon
made all-purpose stone tools that we're
ice age version of the edge that's no
24,000 years down at the bottom Michael
you know are you saying the Smithsonian
are wrong on this Michael you're jumping
to conclusions before you even read that
you want to be right so badly you didn't
read the part and other animals don't
have on a second confirming that humans
had butchered horses and other animals
there 24,000 years ago it says it right
there and you are arguing against two
without even reading it which means you
want to be right no no that's absolutely
Brett's goodness I have no dog in this
fight
we started pointing at you being your
published skeptic magazine and you have
no dog in the fight you're asking me why
don't mainstream archaeologists accept
you should be skeptical if there's hens
about okay call it whatever you want
it goes back 11 through what do you
think about what that says that there's
evidence they butchered horses 24,000
years ago okay I would have to check the
site on I haven't seen this article well
now that you have seen it not my problem
opposing this and you're saying there's
no evidence you have needing article
okay
I'm not opposing anything I'm saying you
certainly this is the reason why
scientists accept these dates here
because there's lots and lots of
evidence for that is scientist in eleven
thousand twelve that is not a scientist
and you say you find one person that
says 24,000 another one like two weeks
ago it's not one person this is without
really doing any research about and then
and then the article is titled what
happens when an archaeologist challenges
mainstream thinking Smithsonian in the
month of March okay Jax Hank Mars it was
a brutal experience something that sank
Mars once likened to the Spanish
Inquisition at conferences audiences
paid little heed to his presentation
giving short shrift to the evidence etc
etc etc result was always the same when
he proposed that bluefish caves was
twenty four thousand years old it was
not accepted what the Smithsonian are
saying is now this is accepted you need
to get up to speed
date of Michael okay my my archaeology
friends like Jared Diamond who I just
checked with on this who's at UCLA he
certainly has a dog in the fight and any
well he just says here's the problem for
50 years people proposed pre-clovis
examples recites or evidence they never
hold up they always the dating turned
out to be incorrect this the carbon-14
was not calibrated right there was this
there was that they never hold up if so
essentially your yeah you lie for 50
years
well you're quoting a friend who says
the evidence hasn't held up before
instead of quoting these articles with
these scientists we're talking about the
data that's showing the human beings
butchered horses 24,000 years ago you're
disputing it just because you talked to
a friend I'm saying that that has to be
confirmed that particular why are you
against it I'm not arguing against
certainly were no I'm just saying that
what this is my right I feel you were
arguing against it and saying that it's
not the case and I don't like it and you
seem to be if I'm correct you seem to be
a Clovis first advocate but you put your
reputation on the line and say you
haven't I'm not gonna put a label on it
I'm gonna say in the latest evidence
that that overwhelmingly shows humans
coming across the siberian straits into
north america
11 12 13 14 15 thousand years that they
definitely did then they definitely did
that
now what did they before what could push
it back much earlier it would be if they
came by boat okay so like where I live
in Santa Barbara there are sites on the
Channel Islands data go back 11 12,000
years ago and they came by boat now the
problem is is well if they lived on the
shores which is where the good fishing
and eating is those are underwater and
in short of doing good underwater
archaeology which is hard to do
inexpensive and most of it's probably
gone we may never know so one of my
beefs with archaeology actually is that
10 million square miles of the planet
that were above water during the Ice Age
are under water now and marine
archaeology is still mainly looking at
shipwrecks you know well it okay they do
that because it's it's the place it's
where the light is it leaves a big
unanswered question at any rate so for
the record it can I at least say that
you completely oppose the Smithsonian's
position on this that there has been no
paradigm shift at this I haven't seen
this alright I'm not aware of the horse
fine from 24,000 years ago I am aware
the 130,000 year date from the
nature paper to have a slide on that too
and and if okay but what's your
circulation tools they're nothing like
Clovis points it's just a big like hand
rock that might have been used it might
have been random sorry a big hand Rock
is all there is before thirteen thousand
years ago no I'm talking about the
hundred thirty thousand year old we
don't we don't need to talk about that
well that that raises interesting
questions was it Neanderthals was it
Denisovans was it anatomically modern
humans 130 raises interesting questions
president is interpreted site because
they are don't I'm not I'm not putting
anything to that I'm just I'm saying yes
that question just about the stone tools
it's about how the bones were shattered
and they believe the bones are shattered
deliberately indicating that someone's
trying to get at the marrow indicating
or maybe or a tractor rolled over it you
know a couple years no one excavated
that's just speculation this was one of
the immediately defined has been
quibbled by the archaeological
mainstream of course it's been published
by the archaeological mainstream too and
the rest of the mainstream is quibbling
it's a whisper that plans that you said
that can't happen we will say what can't
happen that the mainstream won't allow
you know radical ideas nature published
it and the article the idea is being
quibbled would not only it's okay nature
certainly would not have published it if
the evidence were not strong I accept
that nature's not in the business of
publishing you know fringy stuff it's it
is it is a radical proposal but it's
strong enough to justify publication in
nature what's interesting to me is that
the immediate reaction of the
archaeological community is not say well
what could this mean let's let's look
into the implications of this I mean if
there were Neanderthals or Denisovans in
North America 130,000 years ago we have
a whole new scenario building here that
really should interest everyone instead
of say instead of the first reaction is
let's destroy this because it's really
annoying let's get rid of it let's prove
it's wrong let's suggest that it was a
[ __ ] bulldozer or something like that
maybe it was I don't know the work
hasn't been hasn't been done yet but
that instant sort of it's it's almost
like an immune response to it to an idea
that doesn't fit into the prevailing
paradigm but
other work the work in South America the
Bluefish case work that's really not
controversial anymore
that's very widely accepted Clovis first
is a discredited and abandoned position
and I have something else to ask you
actually concerning genetics and and DNA
I'm sure you're well upon that I mean
can you explain why we have a strong
signal of Denisovan DNA in certain
groups of South American Indians and in
Australian Aborigines and Melanesians
but that Denisovan DNA doesn't crop up
in North American Indians how would we
explain that if they all came through
the Bering Strait I have no idea well it
could be boats I mean this just happens
to be something I don't know anything
about okay so part of the problem of
even doing this is that was your idea
well here we are talking this is good
but part of the risk is that you're
gonna find something I don't happen to
know about and then it's like you see I
made my point what point that okay so in
in like the history of the people in of
America that that area there's always
somebody that comes in with it's you
know not Clovis it's this is that and
rarely do they last
why the dates were miscalibrated or
whatever it's not just that scientists
are closed-minded although they can be
it's that the convergence of evidence
isn't strong enough to overturn the
mainstream theory so but but it does
happen you know maybe there are multiple
migrations into North America and we
just don't have all the sites but when
somebody comes up with a site like
that's tens of thousands of years
earlier than all the others that are
accepted here and it's over here
where are all the sites in between where
is it it's like the gap the 5000-year
gap with the Egyptian complex where are
the sites if it's true we they didn't
fly there so how do they get there well
and there must be a trail you know
somewhere that we could find unless they
came by boat and then that's evidences
well unless you're dealing with twenty
four thousand years ago and there's not
much evidence to find that Navy but if
they came by boat then that clearly
implies they had navigational skills
they had the ability to build boats and
and you know find their way across the
ocean you can do the coast that's not
quite as you don't need a you know a big
ocean-going but you don't need an
ocean-going but hypothesis tenure that
that's proposed is that they came across
by by boat just following the shore you
the same area as the Bering Strait yeah
you're just a hundred feet offshore
right go in and most likely both right
and one of the issues of course was the
short-faced bear was so formidable
according to Dan Flores that it would
have been a huge impediment for people
crossing on foot anyway and the
short-faced bear went extinct right
around the time we see more evidence of
human beings entering in but why did it
go extinct that's the big question well
you have to add that to the list of
predators that there would have been no
reason for humans to have been hunting
yeah well it's an enormous enormous
animal so there's sort of two two
factors that go on here there's positive
evidence in favor of a hypothesis then
there's negative evidence against the
mainstream hypothesis and you really
need both so it's not enough to just say
I don't accept the evidence for here
that okay that's fine scientists do that
all the time
what evidence what do you let's be let's
be speaking specifics because you keep
doing this you keep saying well they
find things and it turns out no that's
not true and then you're essentially
like proving your point of being a
skeptic without having any real cases
well just keep saying those the case is
it but but you know you're not saying
you can't say all the cases if you don't
want to cite anything specifically don't
keep bringing up things that are refuted
because you don't have anything that
you're pointing to
so you're just muddying the water okay
you're essentially pissing in the pool
no no the clovis thing for example
gobekli tepe the pyramids all of these
what's been disproved no okay I'm making
a different slightly different point
that's the problem
that is that you you're not addressing
the actual issues we're talking about
you muddy the water by saying things
have been tossed out the window so we
have to be careful here and toss these
things out the window as well not toss
out just contemplate them published in
nature for example so let's watch what
happens to the hundred and thirty
thousand year old hypothesis if it if it
holds up and there's other sites that
are dated that way and so on and so
forth and that will be truly
revolutionary and scientists would
accept it okay well you see the problem
is that when you have a very strong
paradigm like Clovis first which really
dominates American archaeology
prehistoric archaeology for a very long
period it's difficult it's difficult
from a career point of view for
archaeologists to come up and propose
alternative sites those who did like Tom
dinner Haida let
like Jax and Mars paid a very heavy
price for so doing so the incentive to
go looking for older stuff than Clovis
is extremely low in the archaeological
community as a result of this ferocious
reaction that went on for 30 or 40 or
even 50 years you know I mean can also
consider the vasa kilo excavations in in
Mexico where there the suggestion of use
some sort of human presence 230,000
years ago I mean that good archeology
but it was utterly dismissed and the
archaeologists involved were were ruined
for getting involved in that it's hard
to see how that's a profession that
encourages people to think outside the
box when careers get ruined and research
funding gets withdrawn for an idea that
doesn't fit the current mainstream life
we don't like to think that that
scientists do that they do that are you
familiar with Michael Kramer's book
forbidden archeology Michael yeah okay
so now and he makes in my mind as
compelling a case as you do and for his
humans were here tens of millions of
years ago and you know his book is young
nine hundred pages long tens of millions
yet tens of millions okay and he's a
Hindu so his ideas you know this sort of
long recycling and what evidence is it
based well I'm not here to defend
Michael Cremo
or to have a discussion about Michael
Cremo that's not why I'm sitting at this
page yeah but my point is that Michael
Cremo is not me
that's right so but but there's lots of
alternative archaeology who's where I
began there's lots of alternative
archaeology books and right but what
evidence is there that just supports
that none so why are you bringing up
that when there's evidence that he's
bringing up no Cramer's evidence is
similar to his obviously negative
evidence that I don't accept the data
this there is this peculiar sort of
footprint looking thing in the mud Remo
refers specifically to the knowledge
filter the most useful thing about that
book is the publication of reports
archaeological reports which are no
longer available to the public which
which do suggest an alternative view I
would say it's a very useful book to
read beyond that I have nothing to say
about right so but that's not
necessarily true you're saying his only
evidence may be he's pointing to like
some pretty significant evidence like
the Sphinx thing is a geologist from
Boston University proposed this because
of water erosion because a water erosion
that could have only been done by
thousands of years of rainfall in his
opinion as a as a qualified geologist
and that's not a lack of evidence I
understand but why do no no other
archaeologists are killed there are no
it's not true actually they do and I've
had multiple conversations with Robert
where he has cited the fact that he has
gotten a considerable body of support
from other geologists not from
Egyptologists but from geologists who do
recognize the effects of severe water
erosion on limestone
carbonate rocks and that's what we have
there we have a severe water erosion it
appears and is preserved on the quarry
walls around the Sphinx the sinks itself
as Graham said is difficult to ascertain
because of all of the reconstruction
that has gone on but the quarry walls
which would have once had the very
distinct stepped profile of a typical
quarry no longer have that I mean they
have now they have a textbook profile
parabolic profile that would be
consistent with sheet flooding which
would be both dissolution because
carbonate rocks dissolve in acidic
waters and what's called core Asian
which would be the effects of water
loaded with sand sediment which would
make it very rough so if you've got the
sand sediment flowing over the edge of
what would have been a quarry wall what
you're going to end up with is a
smoothing off of the rough corners and
the final result would be a very rounded
profile like you see there and you would
also see where the fissures in the rock
would be selectively widened and opened
by the water penetrating those fissures
I mean it has all the earmarks of a very
textbook case of water erosion don't you
think it's very disingenuous comparing
that to someone who thinks that human
beings have been here for tens of
millions of years with no evidence to
support it whatsoever but he doesn't say
of course he doesn't say he has no
evidence he has a 900-page book full of
evidence it's the quality of the
evidence what about the quality of that
evidence it's okay okay
if it was that good you know we're not
geologists sitting here if it was that
good why don't you all just look at it
go he's right but they know that's the
morning this they do they all do know
some geologists who work with
Egyptologists say that shock is right we
have a geologist on the line why don't
we ask him mark well we can have one
guy's opinion we could also have other
guys opinions that we can get this
matter it has been in what domain since
1992 it hasn't gone away yeah sharks
argument that we are looking at
precipitation induced weathering on the
Sphinx has not been debunked it has been
opposed it has been disagreed with but
that is different from saying it's
debunked and shock stays solid and
strong on that issue he is a
credentialed geologist he is a professor
of geology at the University of Boston
he has a right to speak out about this
and he stated his view I happened to
find his view very interesting
especially since it correlates with what
I regard as the interesting astronomy of
the site I think that site has origins
that do go back into the Younger Dryas
that's my opinion I've stated it many
times and I've presented the evidence
that I think under writes that opinion
you and your colleagues are absolutely
at liberty to disagree and you do you
don't think it's disingenuous to compare
that to someone who says something that
defies our current understanding of
human beings and the the actual
evolution of humans okay you're talking
about someone who's saying that human
beings how many millions of years old
tens tens of billions well we know for a
fact right as far if you pay attention
evolution right but that's what we
weren't even humans a million years ago
correct I mean there are creationists
who think okay we're not talking about
them we're talking about Graham I know
but my point was that so here you have
the mainstream scientists and so it's
like there's Graham he seems so
reasonable but there's 50 like him and
each of them thinks that they're there
right they're not there's your language
he seems so reasonable you're right
there you're accusing me of
dissimulation the subject is that I'm
not a man there's 50 like me this is
more tantalizing arrogant idomeni tlie
unpleasant and personal approach Ram I'm
sorry I didn't mean it to sound like
that
I really don't okay okay I have a larger
point that was you accept it yep that
when you're faced with a bunch of
different alternative theories that are
coming in and it's not it's a take
physics I mean every physicist like me
just had Lawrence Krauss he gets these
letters daily of people saying I think I
figured out why Einstein was wrong and
he can't address them all and and
they're smart people they're thoughtful
people they really believe it what do
you do with that that's my point I feel
that's not my problem and if there are
alternatives the other alternative
theories that's not my problem either
it's the problem for the mainstream to
sort it out and figure we just pay
attention to in which all right well I'm
suspicious of this the whole idea of the
mainstream because even looking in the
mainstream you find so many divergent
points of view that I you know I think
that's basically a fiction that there is
this mainstream that has arrived at this
consensus and that there are no
alternative ulterior motives there and
that there are no dogmas that are being
perpetuated there you know I mean I look
at the lot of the geological stuff and
and realize that there are many
different points of view when we get
talked about the these floods at the end
of the last ice age there are many
divergent points of view there is what
could be considered the mainstream yet
even that has multiple interpretations
and the same with this the Komet idea
you know I mean I don't know what
constitutes the mainstream there because
there have been a group that has opposed
it at every turn but at the same time
the group that accepts the comet
hypothesis has continued to grow in fact
there's even a number of individuals
involved that set out specifically to
disprove it or discredit it who are now
basically on board and it has grown from
being a small handful of scientists that
are now 63 scientists from 55 different
institutions that are on board with the
idea that something remarkable happened
at the end of the last ice age it was
probably exogenic meaning something from
outside something from space there's no
consensus as to exactly what that was
which would be normal because it these
discoveries are in their infancy at this
point but there's been an attempt to
discredit the idea simply because that
as the evidence has come in over the
last decade
it has evolved in in new mysteries have
been opened up as the evidence comes in
and the claim is being made well there's
no consistent interpretation of this
evidence and therefore we've debunked it
I mean an example is Pinter's Requiem
pintura Dalton requiem for the Younger
Dryas impact hypothesis I mean the
publisher paper in PNAS saying Requiem
suggesting that the impact hypothesis is
already dead that was in 2011 every
single one of Pintas points have been
responded to those who are critical of
the Younger Dryas impact hypothesis
rarely cite the fact that the so called
refutations have themselves been refuted
that new information is constantly
coming in I see a very one-sided game
being played here with a group of
academics who are determined to
demonstrate that there could have been
no possibility of anything like a comet
impact twelve thousand eight hundred
years ago and that these 63 or 65
scientists who are proposing that I just
completely wrong and when they refute
the refutations I very rarely see that
referred to or commented upon at all
again your your colleague diff'ent has
you know dismissed the Younger Dryas
impact hypothesis without actually going
in detail into the debate that's gone on
he has this graph in his paper showing
all these different dates for the that's
from one of the critical papers you know
there's another side to this island and
so he needs to be he needs to be
listening to what the other side would
say well that's the point where maybe we
should have mark diff'ent come on and
maybe we should have Malcolm lecompt
come on as well because Malcolm LeCompte
is actually one of those 63 Younger
Dryas impact scientists well what is
that would explain to people that are
just listening to this what is this
graph that you're showing well this is
the carbon-14 date ranges from samples
taken from the Younger Dryas boundary so
this is the boundary here and at the
point of this is that there's not a
single consistent series of dates that
would consistently show yep absolutely
for sure at every site it comes in right
there is that they bounced around a lot
here so now maybe mark this is you know
his area he could come on and Skype here
they bounce around and what's what's the
point of this for the layperson who's
listening to this well so if you take
the ones that above the grey line
then those were those are showing that
something like an impact happened much
earlier or much later and the ones below
it or that it's you know much earlier so
where is the consistency of a single
impact consistent across that middle
vector I don't think there's any
argument there was a single impact in
fact there's there's arguments that
there's no there's more than one date
we're talking about a stretch of
thousands of years and multiple and dry
runs one random two hundred years
Randall please please give me your your
because you're the expert at this well
these are dates for the Younger Dryas
there's a big spread obviously but
there's also a lot of possibilities for
introducing inaccuracies into the dating
the what's called the old would effect
can sometimes make make it appear to be
older than it is by a millennium or two
millennium but what we certainly do see
here is a clustering right around
thirteen thousand years ago that looks
pretty evident to me and everybody knows
who does radiocarbon dating that the
dating might have errors and
inconsistency
in it the one article I think that came
out last year by James Kennedy and 25
others was the biasion chronological
analysis consistent with synchronous age
of twelve thousand eight hundred thirty
five to twelve thousand seven hundred
and thirty five calibrated years before
present for younger dryas boundary on
four continents
that's a refutation of precisely what it
is it's a refrigeration of this mark the
fat does not refer to that reputation
Jamie could you pull up the age of Leo I
think I gave that to you and go to slide
number 167 Wow 167 and that that refers
to the Gotoh slide one hundred to
sixty-seven Jesus you're not [ __ ]
around
167 slides there we go
there we go a cosmic impact event at
twelve thousand eight hundred calibrated
years before present formed the Younger
Dryas boundary layer containing peak
abundances in multiple high temperature
impact related proxies including cereals
milk glass and nano diamonds by yishun
statistical analysis of 354 dates from
23 sedimentary sequences over four
continents established a model Younger
Dryas boundary age of twelve thousand
eight hundred and thirty-five calibrated
years before present supporting a
synchrony ad of the Younger Dryas
boundary layer at high probability 95%
this range overlaps that of a platinum
peak recorded in the Greenland ice sheet
end of the onset of the Younger Dryas
climate episode in six key records
suggesting a causal connection between
the impact event and the Younger Dryas
due to its rarity and distinctive
characteristics the Younger Dryas
boundary layer is proposed as a
widespread correlation datum and Randall
if I can remember what you said
correctly you believed that there was
probably more than one significant
impact over a period of several thousand
years let me let me pop in on that very
very quickly I don't mean to cut you off
go ahead but the the let's be clear the
suggestion is that twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago there was a comet's
break up into multiple parts I mean
anybody who saw the shoemaker-levy 9
NASA films back in 1994 is aware that
that comet broke up into more than 20
fragments all of which hit Jupiter
sometimes creating explosions larger
than the earth itself all right so I
don't think it's controversial that
comets break up into fragments and this
is the suggestion of the Younger Dryas
impact hypothesis that we're dealing
with a giant comet that broke up into
multiple fragments that orbits in the
torrid meteor stream and that four of
those fragments that's the the
suggestion for largest fragments fell
out of the torrid meteor stream coming
in on a trajectory roughly northwest to
southeast crossing the North American
ice cap and there there are up to four
impacts on the North American ice cap
the the the the impact has then
continued across the Atlantic Ocean
there's a suggestion of impacts in
Belgium and indeed as far east as our
herrera in in in syria it's a it's a
global event 50 million square
kilometers of the earth surfaces is
within the Younger Dryas boundary field
it's a really huge thing so this is
justin is that there were multiple
impacts at the beginning now the next
question is what happened eleven
thousand six hundred years ago when the
Younger Dryas ends and global
temperatures shoot up incredibly rapidly
and the science on that is much less
advanced than the science on the
beginning of the Younger Dryas Fred
Hoyle back in the 1980s was puzzled by
the sudden temperature increase at the
end of the Younger Dryas and he
suggested prescient Lee I would say that
this may have been caused by a comet
impact in an ocean so maybe other bits
of the torrid meteor stream impacted the
earth other filaments within the stream
impacted the earth eleven thousand six
hundred years ago or maybe something
else caused it I mean Robert Schoch is
is in favor of extraordinary solar
activity being responsible for that
warming we don't absolutely know but
that that's broadly the suggestion we're
at the beginning in the end it certainly
impacts at the beginning possibly
impacts or other things at the at the
end Club in Napier and others Duncan
steel and other astronomers have
speculated that there could be impact
eras epochs in which there's an enhanced
possibility of the earth being impacted
particularly if you have a large comet
that enters into the solar system begins
to undergo a hierarchy of
disintegrations and basically litters
the inner solar system with material and
we do know that the earth crosses the
torrid meteor stream twice each year
once in late June and once in late
October early November and we know that
the Tunguska event of 1908 which is not
speculative I mean that happened it
occurred on June 30th which would have
been the peak of the torrid meteor
shower it also came from the direction
of the Sun it's its position in space
where it were it emanated it's radiant
point in space from which it emanated at
that time was totally consistent with
the torrid meteor stream radiant so it's
very possible that the that the Tunguska
event of 1908
was a member of that family of
meteorites and so you know that would be
again we don't there's no nothing
definitive there but it would be a prime
candidate for investigation that perhaps
and again I mentioned earlier this goes
back to the work of Fred Whipple way
back
in the 1940s who began to research the
[ __ ] meteor stream and came to believe
that it was much much more active in in
the past than it is now that it's an old
defuse meteor stream that at one time
and like Graham said you know it's it
has multiple objects still within it
comet Encke II is the best-known comment
that's a fragment of the original giant
of the original giant comet that they
estimate might have been based upon the
amount of material still remnant in the
zodiacal light cloud that perhaps it was
somewhere around sixty miles or a
hundred kilometres in diameter another
thing that I'm that I'm taken to task
for is that that I report the work of
Clube in napier and their suggestion
that the torrid meteor stream is
actually [ __ ] dangerous and that we
should be paying attention to it that it
has had been a hidden hand in human
history in the past and that it can
cause us trouble in the future now this
is not gloom and doom we have the
technology to deal with the large
objects in the Touareg meteor stream if
any filaments are on an earth an orbit
that will result in impacts on the earth
at the very least it's extremely unwise
of us not to pay attention I'm accused
of being as I would do Munger and
constantly predicting the end of the
world and this and that but actually I'm
simply reporting astronomers who are
very concerned about the torrid meteor
stream and the possibility that we may
face further impacts from it
in the future that's not wool wool that
is science you know absolutely and I
would agree with that and that's that
and that is a form of catastrophism that
scientists accept is very real there's
some do that well lots I mean there's
you know then what if anything do you
oppose about what they've just said
nothing nothing nothing about the
Younger Dryas period so I just a
technical question you had your slide
was 12,800 on there and so get gobekli
tepe the you know the oldest c14 dates
or what nine ninety so all right so
that's a 1200 year gap well no no
gobekli tepe we to be very clear about
about the Younger Dryas one of the
puzzling things about it is that you
have Cataclysm at the beginning and this
global temperature slump is sure
the cataclysmic by any standards and you
have Cataclysm at the end you have a
massive spike a huge increase in global
temperatures and you have melt water
pulse 1b you have a lot of water going
into the ocean at that time so both ends
of the Younger Dryas are cataclysmic and
it's at the recent end of the Younger
Dryas eleven thousand six hundred years
ago that we Seco Beckley Tepe
mysteriously popping up and I know
you're a staunch opponent of Atlantis
and that you believe Plato made Atlantis
up in order to make a political point
and you may be right but the date that
Plato puts on the submergence of
Atlantis is eleven thousand six hundred
years ago nine thousand years before the
time of Sol on which happens to coincide
with melt water laws 1b and the end of
the Younger Dryas which I would have
thought would cause you to rethink your
position on Plato just a little well
it's interesting
hmm I'm open to the idea I tend to read
myths in the same way your guests
Jordan Peterson does that you know it's
a story to deliver some sort of moral
homily to us it's a commentary on our
own culture or society it's a way a
literary way of delivering a message to
people that's how I tend to read instead
of reading them like let's see if we can
figure out what happened historically
but if there's hard data there's hard
data in Plato's whatever you think it is
and that hard data is data is that the
submergence of Atlantis happened 9,000
years before the time of soul on that is
a date that is 9600 BC that is eleven
thousand six hundred years ago this to
me is a strong reason why we shouldn't
just completely dismiss Plato's notion
of a lost civilization of the idea I
mean the idea that say the parting of
the Red Sea happened because of some
impact that's not I'm not proposing that
please don't go there I'm not waste of
time okay but but there are people that
think that I don't okay or or that the
plagues of the Bible can be a waste of
time but deal with Plato alright so but
my point is that some of them may have
historical origins some of them may be
completely made-up his mythic stories
for some other reason you have to take
them one at a time in my opinion the
Plato one is a commentary on his own
culture of Athens and being too
bellicose being too warlike and that
this is not good for where we're going
that's my opinion and the the fact that
he picks a date that coincides with the
geologically significant date of
flooding is not really gonna change your
opinion I think well I think again
that's pretty amazing coincidence is it
I mean it we refine the election that
Plato
I mean we're Plato said civilization
with with advanced agriculture advanced
architecture advanced navigational
abilities which was submerged by the sea
swept from the face of the earth so that
mankind had to begin again like children
with no memory of what went before and
lo and behold he puts a geologically
significant date on that a date that we
ourselves have only known is significant
in the last 20 or 30 years mm-hmm so
where is this place
this Atlantis I mean so as you know
there's all my problem is there's a long
history of people speculating if we
found a site that would be a big plus go
do more marine archaeology well if we if
we take it literally obviously then it's
below the ocean but I you know I I don't
necessarily take Plato's account
literally but I do say well it's rather
coincidental that he's his dating falls
exactly on meltwater Poulsen one be when
we know there was huge influx of water
into the ocean and also if we look at
the his geography it's interesting
because he sites you know basically a
landmass west of the pillars of Herakles
which is Pillars of Hercules the Straits
of Gibraltar and he places this in the
essentially in the mid-atlantic I think
it was grant or one of the comp the the
commentators on on him that said it was
something like three or four days sail
west but if you look there there is a
sunken landmass that sank at the end of
the last ice age because of the rapidly
rising sea level and this has been well
established by marine geology looking at
evidence that did the Azores plateau
underwent and isostatic subsidence which
would have been resulting from the
rapidly rising sea level we know there's
no doubt that the North American
continent has rebounded isostatic Lee
after the removal of this tremendous
mass of ice that mantle North America up
to anywhere from a thousand to possibly
1500 feet well if you if you do a
comparable isostatic adjustment of the
mid-atlantic ridge you'll find that the
Azores
complex are much much larger and it
turns out that that might actually be a
nice place to develop a at least a
maritime culture something along the
lines of the Phoenicians or the Minoans
during the period of the Ice Age because
during the period of the Ice Age the
climate of the world was so much
different than now you know the Great
Basin area was filled with huge lakes
vegetation forests savanna and
grasslands like Graham said with this
lowered sea level there were much larger
areas of the coastline you were exposed
and that's probably where most of people
would reside it during the Ice Ages near
the coastlines because that would have
been the most benevolent place with the
rising of the sea level all of that's
lost and there's nothing really fringed
about saying well people might have
lived on islands in the Mid Atlantic
especially when we know that the that
those islands most likely had a
benevolent climate during the Ice Age so
III don't go into you know crystal
technology and flying machines or
whatever all of this imaginative stuff
that has accreted to it but if we just
keep it simple and say well is it
possible that a culture along the lines
of the Minoans or the Phoenicians could
have existed could they have existed on
an island culture in the mid-atlantic
and there's nothing really it's you know
extreme about that idea in my mind even
the idea that a more advanced
sophisticated technical of a
technological culture coexisted with
hunter-gatherers isn't too strange I
mean we we essentially do so today we
coexist we thought together as rewards
in jungle who don't even know we you
know we exist I mean so I I don't see I
don't see why a priori that's just an
impossible idea to look I miss
remembering that you in your book you
mentioned Indonesia as a site for
Atlantis I mentioned I mentioned gunung
padang not as a site for Atlantis that's
Danny Hillman Natalie jaja who is a
geologist
he's the Indonesia's leading expert in
megathrust earthquakes as a matter of
fact he has written a book proposing
that Indonesia was Atlantis and that
Gunung Padang which he's been involved
in investigating is a site from
Atlantean times
he has Danny has proposed that now
what's interesting about Indonesia is
that Indonesia sits upon the Sunda shelf
and the Sunda shelf was one of the parts
of the world that was most massively
flooded at the end of the Ice Age now if
you go back to the end of the Ice Age
you're not looking at the Malaysian
Peninsula you're not looking at the
Indonesian islands out going out towards
the Philippines you're looking at a
giant continent sized landmass all of
which went underwater at the end of the
last ice age really rather rapidly so I
think he has a point I think it's an
interesting it's it's one of those areas
in the world where there was very
large-scale flooding huge amounts of
land were swallowed up also Sahel the
the connection of Australia to New
Guinea during the Ice Age was also
washed away there's there's a you know a
whole range of issues regarding sea
level rise in that very area which
anybody with an interest in these
subjects should be paying attention to
so it's quite possible that like today
many of the advanced civilizations of
today are on the water whether it's New
York or Los Angeles and that was
probably the case back then and so the
idea of Atlantis might not have been
about one particular area but many
advanced areas that were wiped out along
with their knowledge yeah I mentioned
Noah's Flood that the the two geologists
with the black sea thick theory that
there were you know it was rimmed with
small villages and you know the massive
flooding almost instantly wiped out and
then that gets passed down as you know
the oral tradition is these myths to me
that seem totally reasonable totally
reasonable yeah well when we get into
more discussion about the actual impact
hypothesis and the major flooding so
that we can get our you know solved what
is your geologists your geologists since
you're by yourself and there's two of
them what is your only fair right what
is your geologist opposed to what Randal
and Graham are proposing I think it's
the on the impact hypothesis versus the
multiple glacial dams that burst over
periods of time like that have that
slide okay well let's call him up and
get him on skype it and we've never done
this before
so this might suck well hopefully it'll
work see this this slide here
he is showing these are each independent
carbon 14 dates of these different
instant floods in North America right
from in each individual ice dams and
what separates these dates they're
separated by 20,000 to 12,000 so all
before the impact well 12800 wasn't that
one marks on the line what is this mark
would it Mar can you hear us yes mark
defend mark defend thank you very much
for doing this we really appreciate you
coming on here my pleasure
so you've had a chance to listen to
these guys talk what what is your
thoughts just stepping into this cold
well first of all I did not mean to
upset mr. Hancock there seem to be quite
disturbed no no you haven't missed it
you haven't disturbed me and I'm not I'm
not upset it's just simply that you're
extremely selective in what you present
in your in your draft admittedly draft
article that you've chosen to put online
you don't represent you don't represent
me accurately we have plenty of time
okay well first of all tonight would you
allow me just to address sure would you
like to address the article first I
think that probably would be the most
fair since we just brought that up okay
what was the question
Graham well the quicker I read out
on-air various passages in your article
where you misrepresent me no I did sorry
no I didn't you didn't misrepresent me
okay so thank you you said that I that I
said that I was actually talking about
someone in Indonesia when I said you
didn't understand Newton's physics you
say sorry I did you say I didn't say you
were talking about someone in Indonesia
I said you were talking about hey hey
hey Suz Kamara in in Peru is who I was
talking about and hey Suz Kamara does
have very
exotic views on gravitation which I
state seriously are not my interest I do
say he may be right but I don't say he's
right I say this is not my interest and
I got to say what my interest in this is
his work you pick up now you're drowning
me out here I was asked to explain
whether or not I thought I was
misleading and I don't think I was
misleading you clearly stayed in there
that maybe gravity was due to the way
we've changed orbits around the Sun
gravity is not due to that it's due to
no I just ate that mass and the inverse
of what what do you mean I don't state
that hey sue sue Kamara states that as I
say I disagree with it come on I say I
want to be I want to be respectful I
can't really hear you when I'm talking I
apologize but I I feel like you've you
are selectively selectively changing the
meaning of what I'm saying well why
don't you quote me as these words from
my text when you say that I by the
gravity thing of hey Suz Kamara
why don't you quote me when I say what I
got to say not quoted in the attack is
the following quote however this isn't
the part of his theory I'm interested in
where I feel he is solidly persuasive is
in his observations of the anomalous
character of the monuments of the Andes
I am not killing anything on his Sue's
Kamara's gravitational ideas I am saying
very clearly what it is in his approach
that I am interested in I'm not going to
dismiss all of his approach because he
has an approach on gravity that you
don't like that's not even of interest
to me and I say so in the book you don't
report that therefore I suggest you
misrepresent me well mr. Hancock what I
brought up him floor was simply to state
that you didn't understand and I say it
right there that you don't understand
Newton's physics but I'm not even
talking about you I'm not talking I
insist if you don't understand not if
I'm if I wished if I wished to make an
argument about gravity I wouldn't
go saying that that isn't the part of
hey soos Kamara's theory that I'm
interested in I'm interested in the
other aspect of his work his
observations through my years of
fieldwork yeah my point was simply to
point out that she didn't understand
grab hold of these guys talking about we
did this represent we did yeah the way
the sentence is structured it's clearly
out of context we're chained we're gonna
change that yeah I was taken out of
context and that's what I'm objecting
I'm not sure why he included in the book
of the first place but he's not arguing
about the gravity at all so we will fix
that maybe we could get straight to the
the flooding thing that that as long as
Graham is fine with that I mean Graham I
know there was something else yeah the
other the other thing that I find to be
misrepresenting is that the statement
yet Hancock makes the following stunning
claim quote our ancestors are being
initiated into the secrets of metals and
how to make swords and knives what mark
de fab does not tell his readers is that
I make that claim I don't make that
claim I am actually reporting what is
said in the Book of Enoch that's not me
who say well first the Book of Enoch
Graham will fix it okay otherwise let's
get let's get back to the main need of
this for God's sake okay just give me
the list of things that you know and
I'll fill well we'll fix it you know
that's not the point in it well mark
you're obviously very critical of
Graham's work and maybe erroneously so
but let's let's get to what you think
about what you've heard so far all right
mr. Rogan I I don't want to come across
as a as a pompous scientist what I want
to do is I want to protect people from
these grandiose assumptions Graham in
his first mr. Hancock in his first book
please call me grab their currents
please call me Graham okay Graham in his
first book in fingerprints suggested
that that there was a continent where
this civilization lived and through some
Maxo nations this continent
went south and and ended up destroying
that civilization well as a geologist
that that's just that's just nonsense
and now he comes back he wants us to
believe that he was all wrong and then
all of a sudden it's okay now to believe
in comet strikes trying to kill this
this famous civilizations not supposed
to exist so Moss is duping people I
don't know if he means to do it master
he seems to be doing mark all my work is
in print and online I mean I see that I
gather that you see your role as a
protector for the public obviously you
feel that the public are not intelligent
enough to make discerning decisions of
their own in this respect however to
address that the public doesn't
understand the science okay so to the
degree so they need the superior
knowledge of mark defend in order to
understand okay let me come to your
point which is you're saying that I
proposed one mechanism for Cataclysm in
fingerprints of the gods and that I'm
proposing another mechanism for
Cataclysm today what I proposed in
fingerprints of the gods was that there
had been a gigantic Cataclysm in the
ballpark of 12,500 years ago I looked at
a number of possibilities of which the
most striking to me at the time was
earth crust displacement and earth crust
displacement is reported as the work of
Charles Hapgood not my work but I do
report it in fingerprints of the gods as
an excellent theory which explains the
information since I wrote fingerprints
of the gods I've learnt a lot I'd learnt
a lot and I wouldn't want to defend that
theory strongly today I don't know if
you have bought the latest edition of my
book the the paperback edition of
magician's of the Gods but it contains a
chapter saying whatever happened to
earth crust displacement I address the
change of view in this and I think I
have a right to change my view and I
think it's it's healthy that I mean why
would I stick permanently to a view that
I hold in 1995 if new evidence persuades
me that it's wrong I'm sure that's a
good thing not a bad thing
and I'm fundamental proposition is we
had a massive global Cataclysm in the
ballpark of 12,500 years ago so
naturally it's of great interest to me
when a large group of scientists more
than 60 of them over a period of more
than
ten years now present evidence of a
massive comet impact event twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago exactly
there was no surgery you are applying
that there are a lot of people out there
to believe in this there are there are
some people that believe in and I agree
but for the most part I think of taking
an honest view the common hypothesis has
gotten debunked well that's complete
rubbish my that's completely rubbish I
would also point out that in
fingerprints you had people believing
that the end of the world was coming to
2012 now how am I supposed to take you
seriously when you say things like that
and then change your run and we could
all be dead by now I have absolutely
changed my mind on the Mayan calendar I
regard the Mayan calendar is an
interesting technological artefact with
a better estimate of the length of the
solar year than the estimate that we
have with today the Mayan calendar is
based primarily on the position of the
Sun amongst the constellations at the
winter solstice and we are in an 80 year
window when the Sun sits astride the
Dark Rift of the Milky Way between the
constellations of Sagittarius and
Scorpio on the winter solstice that
window is 80 years wide so the story of
the Mayan calendar by the way isn't
actually quite over yet but I'm not
either so not means yes I know exactly
what precession means okay well all of
this stuff that you claim is on a
precession a precession is the is the
earth spinning like a top don't teach it
as matter some guys with running through
comet clouds and yet you're saying that
somehow we're on some sort of cycle
where the Comets are gonna come back and
strike the earth right now sometime
during the next forty years that's what
you said in magicians no that's what
that's what that's what Victor Clube and
Bill Napier and Emilio tsveti Cato say
Michael Shermer for for saying the same
things about other people I want to know
what you think mom you tell me what you
think I am a reporter and I make it very
clear talking to Marc so Marc we got a
we
can't talk over each other like this I'm
a reporter and it is my job to report
the work of other people and I report
the work of Victor Clube bill Napier and
Emilio's petit cadeau all of whom draw
attention to the torrid media stream and
who regarded as the greatest collision
hazard facing the earth at this time and
who specifically indicate that we may
run into a filament of the torrid meteor
stream in the next thirty years that is
going to be very bad for our
civilization when when did I say it had
anything to do with precession indeed as
a clock as a timer as a way of going
back through the ages but I'm not saying
precession is causing this encounter
with the torrid meteor stream and go
find the paragraph where I say that no
no no what you're saying is that we're
on a cycle that 12,000 years ago this
civilization was destroyed and now
you're saying oh that civilization was
so smart that they knew we were going to
go through another shower and we're all
doomed in the next 40 years yeah I
didn't say doomed and in magicians like
you did in fingerprints but we must
conclude that that's your opinion
because I don't know anybody else that
you've referenced on that issue
well after session has nothing to do
with that it's not even on that cycle I
never has a cycle of about about 21,000
years 25 cycles when precession 25,920
years actually it's not for precession
one degree every 72 years give or take a
small margin that is the precession
you're really really teaching
grandmother suck eggs here so anyway I
guess this has just been going on all
day you can't criticize Michael for
bringing up other people that are saying
strange things and comparing to you say
oh no you can't say that because it's
it's not about me it's not true here
you're doing the same thing you're
reporting about other people and saying
nonsense yeah my remark I'm reporting
the work of Victor Clube bill Napier and
Amelia spetic Otto
I also indicate that I strongly support
that work that's as far as I go mark is
very if I can stop you here you so you
think that this comet wiping out all the
Ice Age megafauna theory has been
debunked is that what you're saying
no sir I have not saying that but I
think that if you read the literature
carefully the majority of scientists
right now and I know that this is still
going you know what I like about the
comic people is that they're doing it in
the scientifically right way they're
getting people to review the material
they're getting people to go through
that gauntlet to where they get
criticized they make sure that they do
things right and they get it out there
Firestone did this in 2007 he was
crucified he's come back his group has
come back with a lot of good stuff so I
want to wait and see this plant play out
I said that in my paper that we're gonna
have to wait to get a conclusion here so
I'm not saying that they're wrong but
right now if I read the literature as a
scientist I have to say that the comic
guys aren't getting hit pretty hard what
do you take what do you make of the
latest platinum paper in Nature
scientific reports the platinum anomaly
across North America and it's coincident
in time with the Greenland ice cores and
the Platinum anomaly there what do you
say to that and maybe we can bring him
on the problem with that is is that what
does platinum have to do with the Condon
you know Platinum's are high and
asteroids but they're not high in
comet's comets are icy bodies I saw the
paper I read it I think it's interesting
but I can't for the life of me figure
out how he's correlating it he has in in
the different areas of the Clovis he has
platinum concentrations that are that
that are seemingly not matching up there
outside the the Younger Dryas they're
inside the Younger Dryas I'd like to
like you to show those let's bring let's
let's bring much harder to understand
what he's trying to say let's bring it
doesn't refute the common hypothesis
let's bring Malcolm on since he's one of
the co-authors of the platinum paper
this is gonna get super complicated but
let's try at a time we could only do one
caller at a time apparently well I think
Malcolm you know should have his voice
that's okay to do is he can be helped a
little bit if I may about
gobekli tepe because I bred Schmidt I
know that Schmidt never ever found
anything to suggest that the
anything in the early part of Gobekli
Tepe that that were not hunter-gatherers
they all were hunter-gatherers you know
he found 20 I think I I may be wrong on
this but I think he found 22,000 stone
tools there when he dug that place up
I'm not yes we thought any domesticated
animals he never found any domesticated
grain he found tons of bones of animals
so we know that about a hundred to two
hundred people were probably working on
gobekli tepe at one time and they were
fed by wild animals and grain so there's
no reason to go out on a limb here and
say that some magical civilization came
in and by the way that's another thing
that drives me crazy you're saying that
these guys were magicians you're saying
that they had secret knowledge what
possible secret knowledge they give to
the people that go back heavy how can
you possibly not saying that the word
magicians of the Gods comes from the up
kallu in ancient Sumer and they were
considered to have superior powers than
they were considered to be magicians of
a sort and I should I not report that
because it's there in the Sun their
superpowers I'm not saying that they had
superpowers this the Sumerians who said
that I simply report that you can regard
that as a cop-out if you like but I am a
[ __ ] magician because that's the
direct implication of the app Kowloon
they were the magicians
no I'm saying that they were the
magicians of the gods as they were
called in an ancient culture that's all
I just want your audience to know that
[ __ ] who worked there for 20 years that
hat didn't go there for two days and
look around take some notes and leave
and write a book on it he worked there
for 20 years and he found date with
dates and everything he found that there
were hunter-gatherers there building
those mega lists I don't guess that you
went to if you went to Easter Island can
I say D you found the moai and and you
said oh my gosh there must have been
some secret civilization that made these
moai because stupid hunter-gatherers
couldn't possibly make these will we
know that there were no special people
on Easter Island it had to be made by
hunter-gatherers why would you poopoo
the sorry are you saying you'd have to
call us are you so high you should
yeah are you seriously saying that the
inhabitants of Easter Island were
hunter-gatherers absolutely in fact we
saw on that little island ocean they
have no agricultural you say the Pacific
Ocean 1,000 years ago what do you think
what a big civilization mark please let
him respond go ahead well first of all
have you met Claire did you meet clash
Ned do you know him personally
you know okay well I did meet him I do
know him personally I did record I did
record my interviews with him with his
agreement and and what he states clear I
don't disagree with you that the people
around gobekli tepe were
hunter-gatherers
when gobekli tepe was started what
precisely intrigued Klaus Smith was the
possibility his phrase not mine that
Gobekli Tepe was a center of innovation
a place where new ideas were
deliberately seeded and spread out in
the population
I have clash made on record saying that
I quote him saying that in my book and
that to me is a very interesting
proposition because it suggests that we
have a site here that is being used to
mobilize a population and to transfer to
them the knowledge of Agriculture which
suddenly appears around gobekli tepe
at the time that Gobekli Tepe is
functioning what do you mean by what I
mean by what I mean by suddenly is Klaus
Schmidt BETT stated very clearly that
these are the people the very same
people who made gobekli tepe in Cloud
Schmidt's view are the people who quote
unquote invented agriculture if you
don't mind me interrupting here for a
second what what about Easter Island was
Easter Island established by
hunter-gatherers or not you were saying
not you said you say it was established
by hunt together as I said not I say
Easter Island was an agricultural
society what's it what's that hunt and
gather on a tiny island of you been to
Easter Island I have six times and you
know you can walk across it in three
hours
what's that a hunt and gather on that oh
no you misunderstanding my point is that
these are not sophisticated people
okay sorry you second you sleepy on both
go back a tepee
I think they could you got Schmidt right
and in fact it's a UNESCO site we all
recognized
how important it is but what what I
think Michael and I can understand is
how this ties into some some magnificent
civilization there's nothing there that
indicates that they were influenced by
some other civilization except that they
started out as hunter-gatherers and then
they evolved into a agricultural society
and that's what makes it a great Sun can
I answer you you're seriously saying
that there's nothing there I mean the
largest megalithic site on earth 7,000
years older than Stonehenge is there
there's no background to it no not some
practice or training right the
megalithic site itself is the problem
for me okay
I honestly we've got megaliths in quite
a few sites and by the way you're right
there's a megalith just down the road
from gobekli tepe
and they're probably so that several
other I can see them on maps yeah we
need to get to this wonderful amount of
work to do there you bet so I think
grambler a pretty good agreement okay so
is that I don't think there's any any
need to call upon this great
civilization that you say exists well to
me the simplest explanation is a
transfer of knowledge a transfer of
Technology I've been writing about the
possibility of a lost civilization for
more than quarter of a century that's
what I do I hope that it's a useful
contribution to the debate I mean
archeologists can choose not to listen
to anything I say to dismiss me as a
complete lunatic as they often do to
accuse me as you do in writing of duping
the public of conning the public and so
on and so forth you know you did use the
word conning actually it's in the very
last paragraph of your article because I
got it right here in front of me we will
fix that for my students well it's there
I am left with what I am left with is
that Hancock I mean I'm gonna put my
reading glasses on so I can read this
probably what I am left with this is
quoting you mark is that Hancock has a
real Mac for conning a hellacious number
of people into buying his books I mean
that's a homonym insult it's online in
your article do you stand by it or not
I apologize to you for the use of that
language is that what you want her
because I do sorry you used it in the
first place I think you're misleading
your students why would you say that
you're just putting that on line for
your students as if that's not a big
deal you're putting it on the Internet
and to say you're just putting it online
for your students and you've been proven
incorrect and how many different times
in this article now well about seven
correct I haven't been proven incorrect
well you have you misquote me so you
don't give the contact the neighbor guy
this and even Michael Antigua and even
Michael has said that the skeptic
article will not will not reflect these
out of context statements that you're
making here right so the core is is the
impact hypothesis likely to be true or
not and as an independent phenomenon is
it connected to gobekli tepe and the
Younger Dryas i mean that's kind of what
we're getting at so then we can maybe
you can explain that graph that shows
all the the Glacial dam bursts and the
dating of those as as thousands of years
before the 12,800 year in put the map up
first we need to map you guys what did
that what does that mean well which map
is that which maps on your which map
marked I'm sorry it's the Glacial map of
Western Washington or Washington State
yeah okay Jamie put it up I should to
protect Michael here I I submitted this
Michael made immense amount of changes
on that paper I put it up because I
wanted my students to see it I had no
idea that people would go online and
look at that and unfortunately you've
sent tens of thousands of people
probably to it by letting them know it's
on here and I'm sorry for that is it
okay to just put that up online for your
students how come you don't have any
problem with that but you do have a
problem with it as it stands being
released to the general public
well you know if I stand by everything I
said except for the personal comment at
the end
surviving process yeah let's okay let's
put up this math get back to the mail
okay
the brown areas are no I have to
emphasize that that the scablands is
very famous people have been working on
geologists have been working on this for
more than a hundred years I bet and very
intricate detailed mapping and we now
know what areas have been flooded that's
in the brown the green areas are the old
Latian lakes one of them you can see is
the Columbia Lake and the other one on
the far right over in Montana
that's Lake Missoula now I guess my my
point here is is that you guys want to
make the flooding out here to be immense
and I think Brett's you know original
idea was that there was just one
flooding but then Brett's came to
understand after looking at the data and
all of the geology geologic work that it
wasn't just one flood that it's many
floods and that was the point of all of
those dates that I've shown you that
there were there have been at least
seventeen specific floods dated there
probably as many as 40 to 50 floods out
there and they're all probably related
to a glacial dams breaking now where in
the world would you ever say that this
small area relative to a entire
continent why would you say that this is
evidence for a comma strike comet strike
not even the comet guys are saying that
this flooding out here is related to a
condom because there are a large number
of area a very small number of very
actual area that is flooded if you take
a look now at my dates or not my dates
but the days do you have that Michael
we're gonna bring that up but let's let
Randall Carlson address usually because
he's where this I mean he's got a point
that if you just look at if you confine
your your examination to this area but
the point is is you've got evidence of
mega flooding all around the ice sheet
margin from the Atlantic to the Pacific
got the work of P hue and Lord in the
Midwestern states South Dakota North
Dakota eastern Montana you've got
massive spillways out there that
discharged it off the ice sheet you have
glacial River Warren that was
undoubtedly formed by most likely
glacial Lake Agassiz
and you've got the st. Croix River where
I took Graham a couple of years ago that
had mega floods down it there were mega
floods down the Mississippi River
there was glacial lake Wisconsin that
discharged down the Wisconsin River left
the Wisconsin Dells there are the Finger
Lakes in New York that probably were
created by massive floods emanating all
of the scour scoured exactly right they
were scoured and they were probably
scoured by sub glacial floods that were
coming under high pressure because you
know you have the drumlin fields that
are just to the south of them and you've
probably seen the work of John Sean
flare beany and Bruce Rainey and nose
out of Canada
well why would that be why would how do
you propose the drumlins then were
formed Oh easily these lasers came
forward and topped top to the terminal
moraine and spread the Marines out to
the ended Romans it but how I mean
you've got you got features that look
like they're totally flew viele produced
you have they look like inverted bow
tells you look at the internal
stratification how does glaciers create
internal stratification I've looked at
you had looked at at numerous drumlins
from in Canada I've looked at drumlins
in New York State I've looked at
drumlins in probably a dozen different
places and where you can see exposures
you see stratification you don't see if
if glaciers are grinding over deformable
substrate how is it that they produce
anything other than a chaotic jumble of
glacial till you can actually see layer
I've seen it myself and we can pull up
pictures of it here in a minute and I'd
like you to explain to me to do that
because I'm not disagreeing with you
okay a Drummond by definition is made up
of till I think we're getting kind of
technical for this audience but you know
an esker is something that's stratified
not a drumlin so you're miss you miss
identifying them as drumlins no I am NOT
miss identifying drumlins I know very
clearly the difference between an S car
and a drumlin I've looked at many askers
I've hiked on them I've flown over
airplanes the Finger Lakes are dashed
they are gouged yes are they gouged by
glaciers or are they also gouged by sub
glacial mega floods that's the question
in that I think that's a fair question
to ask and if we look at some of the
studies we find out that the the
depositional material in them is massive
it's not stratified it's massive as if
it was dumped in there over a very short
period of time let me go back but hold
on a second
would you please your point about that
yeah I'm sorry respond to that what he
just said what am i responding to oh
look we're gonna have to disagree I mean
what am I supposed to argue I don't want
getting an argument with him here he
thinks that they're done by water I
think that the traditionally the way
most geologists see the grit the Finger
Lakes is their couched out they're
parallel to one another if he thinks
it's water okay what can we do we can
disagree I guess well let me go back up
to the main glacier the red tide glacier
Wally Broecker suggested at 90 in the
90s that water potentially was changed
from flowing down the Mississippi Valley
into the Atlantic or the artic no one
has been able to find any evidence of
flooding towards the Atlantic or the
Arctic so when you say there are all
kinds of evidence of flooding up there I
meant Wally Broecker backed off of his
of his theory because we couldn't find
any floating what he backed off of was
the the idea that the draining of
glacial Lake Agassiz triggered the
Younger Dryas because the direct the
dating of the draining of glacial Lake
Agassiz was post Younger Dryas and so
that's what he backed off of
he didn't necessarily backhoes look we
know that network there were some when
trains have been carefully
they've been carefully math you can
watch the Elan tie glacier move back
Lorain after moraine and there are no
holes in that moraine that that suggests
flooding there's no change in the lake
level of Lake Agassiz there's no
evidence there Randall for flooding
you've got it wrong if you look at the
mapping that the careful mapping that
the geologists have done you've just
said that there was no change in the
level of Lake Agassiz how is that
possible I mean as the ice receded the
glacial Lake Agassiz expanded and at
some point it finally breached right
there at by big stone lake in Minnesota
and and basically carved out the
Minnesota River Valley which geological
studies have confirmed they called glia
River Warren and have confirmed that
essentially it was carrying its pay peak
discharge was roughly four thousand
times greater than the modern Minnesota
River that flows there and we're into
the Mississippi the Mississippi then
conveyed that water into the Gulf of
Mexico and deposited huge amounts of
Delta material that New Orleans is built
on now you know you're trying to make a
flood were a flood isn't there's a
difference between a glacier melting
which causes a lot of water and a common
striking in which case is it creates
copious amounts of water I think you
guys referred to it the last time it's a
tsunami there's no evidence of a tsunami
in North America have you been by the
way here's another question why do you
guys why are you guys talking about
North America when you're Atlantis is
supposed to be in Egypt or you guys have
run around you found some evidence of
flooding in North America and somehow
this relates to a destruction of
Atlantis and some lost civilization I'm
talking about now I'm not talking about
that we know there was a fan of scandia
and Ice Sheet we know there was a
Cordilleran Ice Sheet we know there was
a Laurentide Ice Sheet we know they all
melted we know that there was somewhere
around six million cubic miles of ice
wrapped up in those in those ice sheets
at the end of the
glacial maximum they're all gone now
they had to melt that was an enormous
amount of water and I don't know if you
have been out to the scablands I've been
going back to the scablands and the area
of glacial make Lake Missoula since 1970
I've been across that thing 60,000 miles
back and forth I have over 10,000
photographs of the material in the field
and I can tell you those floods were
enormous they were beyond her cherry
picking look at the map you've shown
some pictures you know we can measure
those current ripple marks that you show
we can measure how much water went over
all you have to do is measure ripples
you can go into Camas Prairie and you've
got a current ripple field there that is
about seven miles long they know very
well okay and the high-water mark in
there is at 4200 feet above sea level
the floor of Camas Prairie is just 1400
feet lower than that so we know that
there were 1400 feet of water that
passed through Camas Prairie and down
into the Flathead River no no we know
well because you're disregarding the
high-water mark the bottom up from the
bottom of the canyon to the top of the
canyon is not what it was when the water
first started flowing in that area you
can't take the bottom of the canyon and
say oh there must have been 4000 feet of
water here I'm not talking about a
canyon I'm talking about Camas Prairie
Basin which is not a canyon it's a basis
well most of the material in there was
washed in so I mean we don't know how
much it would have eroded until somebody
does some core samples to get down to
something that can be dated to earlier
you know than the late glacial maximum
but the floor of Camas Prairie is is
thick layers of very coarse gravel
boulders and this is what composes the
the current ripples that you see there I
mean I don't see how you can look at
those current ripples that are sometimes
40 and 50 feet in amplitude with two and
300 feet cord lengths and say that that
wasn't a catastrophic flow maybe it
wasn't for crack it was a catastrophic
flood but it wasn't like a tsunami well
then how would you characterize and we
can you know we can do we can play this
game are you saying
every geologists on the planet
practically says that there were about
40 different floods until you came along
no no no no time you're obviously
familiar you're not familiar with the
work then a Victor Baker or Russell
bunker or a number of others that have
challenged the 40 floods hypothesis and
are you gonna tell me that those current
ripples in Camas Prairie are created
they're the product of 40 separate
floods oh absolutely
in fact when you showed me your pictures
I could see the flow changes in net oh
don't give me the that you're
incredulous stuff I'm sorry I just
doesn't mean you're right you do the
encryption us all the time mark well so
30 floods created the Camas Prairie
that's what you're saying that's what
that's the product of 40 separate floods
those currents how many floods have been
in there I know that there are they're
going there counting them and I and I
last read something the effect of 40
somewhere right yeah that's based on the
work of Richard wait goes back to the to
the early eighties and I think he's got
no go to he go to his graph can we go to
his graph whose graph which graph is
this mark it's the one right below the
man here this one it's the dating ok
floods here we go we're at that right
now
I think hopefully hopefully we're
disagreeing in his comrade - yeah I'm
just trying to give you some data here
look at those those are Missoula floods
late Lake Missoula he's got him dated
you're seeing the dates he's got
standard deviations one and two standard
deviations on on on on the median there
so we've got these these things pinned
by multiple carbon dates the the little
bell curves they're showing how many
carbon dates he's got and you can see
that these are documented very very well
yes so I don't understand why you're
you're you're so opposed to multiple
floods in fact I heard in the last time
you guys were on
show I heard you say that you thought
there were multiple floods now you try
NAR no not I'm still I still think there
were multiple floods I think we have to
look at two distinct regimes of floods
though and and and as far as the the
radiocarbon dating the thing we have to
be really careful of is that floods will
in train older sediment and in that
older sediment there could be
radiocarbon dated material that doesn't
really date that the time of the flood
but was excavated by the flood entrained
into flood waters and then redeposited
so you know that that's a major problem
with radiocarbon dating any time you
look at flood sediments and I do believe
there were multiple floods deaths you
know I think it's a misinterpretation to
think that I only think that there was
one flood but there you know the problem
is here and I do I think we're
colleagues and I my approach to this is
just like you know in the AMA when two
guys get out there and try to beat the
crap out of each other and then at the
end of it they give each other a hug
that's kind of where I'm coming from so
you know there's nothing personal well
you know I I I really value this because
I'm looking for you know I'm looking for
holes in this idea very much so and and
I have done some serious thinking about
this over many years and I have
interviewed most of the geologists that
have worked on it I've been in half a
dozen field trips guided by the the main
geologists that have worked on this and
had a chance to dialogue with them and
and you know I I'm convinced that you
know there's still some there's a lot to
be learned about this and and I think we
need to be looking at like you said the
big picture and you know we could get
back to a discussion of the Finger Lakes
and how they formed I think that's
important I think we could get back to a
discussion about drumlins and how they
formed you know there is Studies on the
valley heads Maureen that are at the
south end of the Finger Lakes that I
can't think of who did it right now I
could pull it up but basically said
there it's water deposited but but
there's a lot of unresolved issues about
what happened during this transition
planetary transition
out of the last ice age and I think it's
important that we have these discussions
that we have these dialogues and then we
try to get to the bottom of what
actually happened without you know
imposing too many preconceptions upon
our models because I think we're looking
at something very unprecedented here
right now I couldn't have said that
better it was very well articulated let
me go back to the big picture if I could
just for a minute because I want us to
address something that Graham said
earlier and that is that Graham seems to
have this idea that that comets break up
all the time
but but people that understand I think
comets and meteorites understand that
the comet Xuan Levy or whatever it was
that broke up shoemaker maybe nine it
broke up because of the gravitation of
Jupiter we would not expect these comets
to break up and rain into the atmosphere
is one of the problems that the comet
people have had the Firestone once
suggested a four kilometer wide comet
striking them and now they've broken it
up into multiple comets the problem is
you can't get it separated if a comet
breaks up it's very hard to separate it
so that it hits in multiple places and
so so this is a big picture kind of
problem that the common people are
having with the scientists so you may be
able to get it to hit the North American
ice sheet but I'm telling you that the
studies are showing that you're not
going to be able to do this without
leaving some marks and so far nobody's
been able to find a credit do you know
that that they're suggesting and a four
kilometer comet if it could break up it
would generate 1 million crater meteor
craters you know how big that was that
was 49,000 years ago we don't see that
in the in the climate record 49,000
years ago we should see that we don't
see it it's about a barely a little
thing
welcome to Compton sweet Stan they have
a huge comet strike Malcolm the comte
has been standing by for best part of
three hours and since he's a member of
the
research group wouldn't it be a good
time to bring it off yeah we can bring
him on as long as mark is satisfied that
he said his piece but unfortunately mark
we can't have two people on the phone at
the same time okay I appreciate you
coming on - and I'm glad you guys
especially you and Randall seem to have
ironed out a lot of your ideas well I
think there's a lot to be learned here
obviously and there's a lot that already
has been learned and this is an
unbelievably fascinating subject and I
think oftentimes when these debates get
heated a lot gets lost and who's wrong
or who's right but I think what we can
all agree on is that what we're dealing
with is an unbelievable point in history
in the history of this planet and trying
to figure out what caused it and why is
some really fascinating stuff so mark I
really appreciate your time and really
appreciate you imparting your knowledge
on us mark if at all possible I would
love to kind of keep some of this
dialogue going because I really would
evaluate I tried to write you Randall I
would have seen that I definitely would
have responded so well connect you guys
after this is over and thank you once
again mark really really appreciate it
if I can just say I do hope you'll
revisit your article and just have a
look at the context in which you present
me thank you Mark okay now we are going
to call caller number two this is a
fascinating podcast and your friend
who's waiting is Malcolm McComb Markham
he's one of the comet research group
scientists this is a large and diverse
body of scientists who come at the
material with different expertise and
different areas of knowledge
it happens that Malcolm is a co-author
of the recent I regarded highly
significant paper finding a platinum
anomaly across North America and I would
hope you might begin with it with
addressing why that might indicate a
comet impact right who's Malcolm on you
should be Malcolm can you hear us
like when I can hear your excellent how
are you Malcolm thank you very much for
joining us happy beer so give us your
thoughts on what Graham just said if you
would as to why why it makes sense that
it was a comment that hit and why there
would be these large deposits of these
what was it exactly
recent paper but but Malcolm is also an
expert in magnetic microsphere eul's and
I think he can arrest that issue as well
the whole range of proxies of impact
proxy in our mouths and Malcolm please
just give us your thoughts on this
entire phenomenon if you were I will be
here happy to have you is he breaking up
go ahead go ahead Malcolm I think
there's an issue seems to be the king
polite I know what's going on I've got a
feedback I've got to turn off this okay
yeah you got a mute that other video oh
okay you're listening to us at the same
time as talking to us yeah yet you're
you're getting us on in like a 40 second
delay or something exactly yeah okay we
call now actually I was very interested
to hear marks his initial statement kind
of put me off but his uh his subsequent
statements I thought were or we're
pretty accurate and there is there are
many problems with the the the
hypothesis that there was an impact and
that's the way I consider I don't really
think in terms of a common impact I
think in terms of an extraterrestrial
impact because I don't think we've
proven a common in fact I don't think
we've proven we I don't think we know
what kind of an impact it was there's
too many questions that have to be
answered so I can't sign up to say that
I'm defending the common impact
hypothesis because I don't frankly know
what it was we have a lot of evidence
that appears to be extraterrestrial in
nature we have magnetic micro sterols I
can give you the most frequent criticism
we get is that the the evidence has not
been replicated and that's where I
thought mark was going when he is
initial statement was that the combat
impact hypothesis has been a debunked
and I think what he meant was if I can
speak for him was that the fact that it
was a comet has been debunked I don't
think that's necessarily true yet it
just doesn't indicate that that it was a
comments we have indications that it was
more of an asteroid hit than anything
else and and I can conceive of a rubble
pile that somehow became disassociated
although there be MEK there have to be a
mechanism or a model for that and I
don't think we have a model for that
asteroids come in many flavors and
rubble piles are certainly one loose
lose aggregates of material that could
become separated possibly but I just
don't you know I just don't know at this
stage I guess the biggest criticism that
we faced in terms of the impact
hypothesis is that the evidence has not
been replicable and we now have I guess
four three or four evidence lines that
have been replicated by numerous
independent groups due to the nano
diamonds which may be the most
controversial of the bunch of the
evidence lines that's been that's been
replicated by four different groups
independent five different studies the
magnetic microspheres which were
initially treated very hostile because
they didn't understand what we were
talking about and some of that was a
self-inflicted wound on the party
initial study which didn't show what we
really were finding and that's been
corrected and if this the same objection
or criticism is being made
magnetic microspheres are typically very
well they're melted and then they're
quenched they said if they're subjected
to high temperatures and then those
temperatures are rapidly reduced which
is sort of accepted to be
characteristics of an impact so we've
got that evidence of an impact and
that's been replicated by ten different
independent groups
and including many of the same site that
that were originally disputed so then
the disputation has been largely based
upon the failure to do the most basic
part of the protocol which is to to do
the scanning electron microscopic
analysis of the sphere holes okay that
that is the Diamonds the other is the
discovery of platinum iridium or osmium
which are the platinum group elements
which are characteristic of an asteroid
impact and we found some evidence of
iridium not not a lot but there have
been certain sites that are rich in
iridium at and once again this is at the
younger driest boundary not at Bob not
below it's there
after that boundary so that date seems
to be pretty solid in iridium is
indicative of an impact of
extraterrestrial origin correct that's
correct
the platinum is simply just another more
more plentiful platinum group element
obviously that's why they're called a
platinum groups osmium is one that is
usually associated with iridium there
are now 11 studies by independent groups
that have confirmed the occurrence of
platinum osmium iridium so it looks to
me like the evidence is piling up the
most recent one of course is the
platinum study by Moore that just came
out Oh a few months ago now Randall
Nelson just I'm sorry to interrupt you
but Randall Carlson just had us pull up
some images that we're looking at
Randall please explain what this is well
this is from Malcolm's 2012 independent
evaluation of conflicting microsphere
results from different investigations
this is his supplementary in information
figure four so it's just so that the
people watching this can can actually
see what you're talking about when
you're discussing the rapid quenching
effect on the surface of the
microspheres so so we've got up on the
screen here supplementary information
figure four where you've got the
microspheres from topper Blackwater draw
and
pappa Cove so just just so people can
see what that surface texture looks like
oh yeah you see these they look like
leaf like structures across some of them
are harder to see but they're there you
see the original image it's large enough
and clear enough to actually see these
what we call dendritic structures or or
almost like a carpet weave mm-hmm those
are essentially truncated
crystallization it's it's a
crystallization process that's quenched
I'm not a geologist a geologist trying
to explain it to me and that's what I'm
trying to do here but you know yeah the
fact that these are enhanced these these
things are quite enhanced
at the average rious and really depleted
above and below now there are spirals
throughout the columns any column of
soil when you go down vertically on a
deeper you find sphero's but those
spheres are typically what we call
autogenic which means that created by
terrestrial processes you need to do a
scanning electron microscope and x-ray
dispersive spectroscopy to differentiate
those from the terrestrial processes
that are producing these things yeah
your figure five has a frame boydle
Sphero which is probably what you're
talking about if you could go to slide
113 Jamie and and you'll be able to see
yeah there it is you can see very
distinct difference so we've got your
figure five up in the screen now Malcolm
this is a typical frame Boyd and there
when you look at an optical microscope
they look just like thee or very much
like the the what we call impacts fuels
or magnetic microsphere holes and they
occur much more frequently I mean I've
got sites that have tens of thousands of
these things in every couple of
centimeters of sediment so you've got to
separate the this that might be the
impact cereals or the magnetic
microspheres from these things but what
you appear to be saying Malcolm is that
there is an abundance of impact proxy
evidence which in your opinion
adds up to a cosmic impact of some sort
not necessarily a comet you're
suggesting an asteroid it's a mysterious
event in that sense but what it adds up
to is an impact in your view um is that
a fair yeah a fair these improper we
call proxies the impacts urals the
platinum group elements the the melt
glass which I haven't discussed yet and
the nano diamonds are enhanced and the
enhancement has been replicated on
numerous occasions for each of these
these proxies so anyone who says that
that the work of you and your team has
been completely debunked is is clearly
not completely familiar with the
literature then that's that would seem
to be the case that our were
disingenuous in that regard well I would
say that that because typically what we
see is that the opposition literature
does not cite the studies that have come
out yeah we try and cite both the
critical studies and hours and give
reasons why our studies supplant theirs
yes I have but I wish they would share
what could you go that hasn't been the
case
slide 82 it would be nice if we could
have had you on with mark so you guys
could exchange information but
unfortunately our capabilities that we
can only take one phone call at a time
we will definitely try to update that
for the new studio although we never
anticipated this was going to happen in
the first place awesome oh there we go
up on the screen
Malcolm we've got from from Ted Bunch at
al 2012 very high temperature impact
melt products as evidence for cosmic
airburst sand impacts twelve thousand
nine hundred years ago so we have figure
from supplementary information six
delight photomicrographs of magnetic and
glassy spheres from Melrose Pennsylvania
and it shows the the wide variety of
shapes which includes spirals ovals
teardrops and dumbbells and I think so
you can see pretty distinctly what
you're talking about here with with the
glassy spirals and then like
particularly I don't not sure if you
were co-author of this paper or not I
was not you are not okay
are you familiar with that paper
do you know the image I'm good okay yeah
it shows some very interesting or
teardrop shapes dumbbell shapes and
where you can actually see that like
dumbbell H up there consists of two
dissimilar accretionary spherules one
clear silicon rich and the other opaque
iron rich that have been fused together
and that's that's pretty convincing
evidence of the of the energy that's
involved in these phenomena the jacks we
have these fused spirals like this and
then Jamie if you go down to the next
image which is a scanning electron
microscope images comparing younger
drivers boundaries fields on the top row
with known impacts fields on the bottom
row this is a very interesting
comparison because and I you've probably
seen this one malcolm a there's there's
three across the top three across the
bottom and a is actually a from
knudson's or nudesons farm in canada
it's a young a Cretaceous tertiary
boundary spiral and just below it is a
younger driest Sphero from lake Cuchillo
in mexico and one can see the
morphological similarity of the two
quite clearly then C and D compares C is
a mural from the Tunguska air burst and
then D is for younger driest boundary
from Linden Germany which dates to
twelve thousand eight hundred years
before present and there you can see
very clearly the the rapid quench melt
texture on the surface between the two
comparison comparing Tunguska air burst
with a younger driest boundary object
and then finally II and F we have an
iron calcium silicon cell from meteor
crater compared with an iron calcium
silica Younger Dryas boundary Sphero
from abu hariya syria and again in each
of these cases you can see the
similarities between the different types
of objects so you have these three
objects which are come from that Younger
Dryas boundary layer all which have
morphological similarity to known impact
proxies and this is very difficult to
dismiss this as being mere coincidence
yeah I would agree and those those are
very especially the ACB
d pictures are very similar to the
material that I'm taking out of the
Younger Dryas boundary at the sites that
I've been looking at uh-huh
Malcolm what evidence if any d are you
aware of about what is that nuclear
glass material called trying try to
Trinitite that's how you say it well
what I understand there's quite a bit of
that that also appears that in the same
time period in the core samples there
are some instances of it but I wouldn't
say quite a bit some of these I mean
they're very site-specific and one of
the one of the things I've been trying
to do is work my way closer and closer
to Canada and see if there's any truth
to them this whole idea that the primary
impact site was Canada so I've been
trying to look at sites closer and
closer and I've seen sites in New Jersey
this would be Eastern Canada I've seen
sites in New Jersey New York and
Pennsylvania that produce what appears
to be some form of Trinitite or melt
glass or what Ted bunch would call
scoria like objects and it seems to to
bear out that that at least that far
we're getting richer material out of the
sediment out of the Younger Dryas
boundary sediment is the Trinitite this
material only produced in this manner or
it's also produced through nuclear
explosion tests right but other than
that is this the only way that it's
produced on earth well an impact would
do it or a fulgurite could do it what is
the right is is what's produced by a
lightning strike could produce a
spherules it could produce all the high
temperature products but you see in an
impact but in a very limited way you
wouldn't expect to see it in a layer
unless there was some sort of global
lightning storm the what I was gonna say
about the melt glass is that in in the
material we're looking at you see
evidence of melted
zarkon's melted chromite all of which
are very high temperature features high
indicating a very high temperature that
was experienced by that
their object are you seeing the image we
have up here yes oh great okay good yeah
they're a is from meteor crater and B is
from the Trinity nuclear test so and
then with the 22 kiloton yield and then
C is from one of the Soviet era nuclear
tests and D is again a scoria like
object from a Bavaria so yeah so and
then if we go to let's see yeah I love
that it says Stalin ight yeah
Korea like objects the the milk glass
was Korea like objects has only been
found and about half a dozen sites to
this point so we're still you know and I
think it's a matter of how close you are
to an impact point and if they're very
far apart that would lend credence I
think to the this idea of multiple
impacts if they seem to be get more you
know more plentiful as you get further
and further north and maybe there's more
more legitimacy to to a primary impact
site right now we just don't know now
we're still we're still working that out
alright we got another nice slide from
from the bunch article here the youth
the careful slide yes calcium oxide rich
scoria like object created by the
melting of carbonate and silica rich
precursor rocks the yellow areas the
calcium oxide the white areas less
Shatila right and dark areas are iron
oxide so that's a really nice let you
tell you right
yeah I've been struggling with getting
that down and then Jaime if you go to
the next one we will see there's a
scoria like object from meteor crater
Arizona and you could toggle back and
forth between the two so the people can
kind of see the similarity between them
and I see a lot that's when I in the
sites that produced milk glass that's
what I'm seeing yeah those two those two
types of particulate and how much this
material are you finding in these sites
well you don't plant I have to say you
don't find a lot of this material it
takes it's a struggle to get it but what
you don't find is anything above or
below it that particular layer unless
you know that there's been a very
dynamic
environment which case it can be spread
out in the in the soil column and what's
the implication of nothing above it and
below it
well that that you've got a specific
date for a specific date for it and the
belayer that we we typically try and
just look at our investigation two
layers that have been dated to the other
driest boundary or contain their driest
boundary layer right well like I say if
you have a very dynamic environment it
can really screw things up it can be
very difficult to interpret so this is
flooding repetitive flooding difficult
science to do sagan this is difficult
science to do yeah and and uh I should
add there that proving an impact is not
easy it takes a while and and it just as
proving an impact crater is not easy as
I'm sure mark would agree that you find
a crater there's no guarantee that's
either an impact impact event or a
volcanic event until you do the research
and spend the time to investigate it but
if you could summarize for us what's
your opinion now on the balance of the
evidence always bearing in mind that you
may change that opinion as more evidence
comes in yeah I would say we're facing
an unprecedented type of event here that
appears to have been something
approaching global I mean we've got
evidence now in South America we've got
evidence and a lot of this stuff is
unpublished like there's a lot of things
that that I could bring up there aren't
published so that it's kind of useless
to refer to them because there's no way
of checking what I'm saying
but we're seeing stuff that goes very
far into South America and we're seeing
things in Syria we haven't looked
elsewhere we've seen how about in the
Pacific Ocean we've seen it in the
Europe so I mean where does it end
and it's all we haven't found an end to
it and it's all at the Younger Dryas
boundary that's correct yeah what have
you found in the Pacific Ocean
well sharma has found there's a paper i
can cite from his his uh may even be
just a presentation in court he says we
infer that the Central Pacific was a
site of deposition of osmium resulting
from dusk from dust cloud following a
meteorite impact at 12
12,000 kill animals plus or minus 4,000
so right net right in that ballpark
Sharma says that he found osmium and I
believe he's come up with microspheres
from that that same core but so the
Central Pacific is an idea that there
gives you an idea of how extensive this
this thing was now Malcolm this is
obviously some controversial material
it's it's it's fairly new in terms of
the public consciousness have you had
anybody debate you on this or if you had
anybody oppose you yeah because it goes
with the territory
I wish the the opposition's in some
respects in some cases I wish the
opposition was a bit higher caliber than
than what I've seen I think it's it's
been a sad state that the most virulent
opposition has not I have I haven't
regarded as particularly high-quality
Mountain Malcolm Michael Shermer here
just do you have an opinion on the the
Association of the impact with the
megafauna extinction and also then
Grahams hypothesis about the you know
extinction of this lost civilization I
the I'm even comment on the lost
civilization aspects of this I have a
hard enough time dealing with a
meteorite impact as far as the megafauna
goes I I think that I guess like I would
say all of the above I think that all
these these factors came into play
you've got humans who are you know for
that period technologically advanced
with with the Clovis point in the the
atlatl and the spear the replaceable
spear tip that must have been
devastating to the fauna but the the
idea of attacking a a promise in Ian to
me is almost unthinkable I mean those
things are today if you don't have a
high-powered rifle I just don't see how
you you realistically go up against a
bull elephant I mean it just strikes me
is far too dangerous take on but there
are aspects of that question that I
think are gonna be very very
interestingly debated in the next the
next couple of years or so we have a
book coming out that addresses that
directly one of the sites I've been
researching that the whole extinction of
the megafauna
may have been as much related to
religion as something else there may
have been a religion built around the
extinction of the megafauna oh how so
that's well that you'd want the evidence
for that and that that evidence will be
coming out in a book and that's gonna be
published in about a month or two oh
well I could speak to the whole idea of
hunting bull elephants though
unfortunately people have been hunting
them with bows and arrows forever it's
not an atlatl atlatl is less effective
yet less range but people hunt with not
just modern compound bows which are very
powerful which would allow you to shoot
from a hundred yards away but with long
bows they've been hunting elephants with
bows and arrows for a long time you know
the especially the thing with woolly
mammoths was that they would go after
the females apparently according to Dan
Flores who wrote american serengeti and
that the females would keep the young in
their body their gestation period was
very long like i believe he said it was
two years is that correct i think he
said it was two years and so it made
them extremely vulnerable when they were
pregnant obviously if you kill off the
females that are pregnant
you're killing off a substantial part of
the breeding population and the
population suffers tremendously so that
was one but it also could have been that
end you know i mean that humans i'm sure
had an impact on virtually anything that
we could eat when we were starving but
whether or not we wiped them out the
Blitzkrieg hypothesis there's a lot of
holes in that theory according to a lot
of people that have studied it well I
think you have it you know if you have
an environmental impact or a degradation
of the environment that might follow a a
significant extra terrestrial impact so
you're you're reducing the population or
stressing the population of megafauna
that way and then you've got a
population of hunters in addition to
that especially if there for some reason
or other focused on hunting Provost in
Ian's and when the number gets limited
they don't care whether it's a female or
a male
and they go after whatever they can get
and I think the population of megaphone
is going to suffer so I think it's a
combination of factors not necessarily
just one yeah I think that's very
reasonable mm-hmm Malcolm is there
anything else you would like to add
before we let you go uh no I I guess one
thing is the interest I found it
interesting in the discussion of the the
scablands and and that was really it was
looking at the scablands from from
flying over them when I was a young
naval officer that got me interested in
science and why I pursued science it was
looking at that the catastrophes that
were etched in the landscape there the
catastrophic floods that really cost me
to pursue a career in science it's
really a remarkable landscape it's just
a personal observation well mark we're
very very thankful for your time and we
really really appreciate your input here
and it means a lot and and thank you for
everything you've done thank you for
everything that you continue to do to
highlight this it is such a fascinating
subject and it's so amazing and it's
just without someone like you presenting
hard data in science it would definitely
be lost so thank you thank you so much
thank you
Thank You Malcolm yeah Thank You Malcolm
all right Malcolm we're gonna let you go
okay take it easy buddy sat down time
for your nap Malcolm it's a lot of
energy so these podcasts are long I mean
four hours guy was sitting there on
standby probably you know chomping at
the bit um Jamie before we go I want to
see some pictures of the scablands
because that is pretty amazing stuff and
Randall one more thing before we go one
thing that you pointed out to me during
one of the episodes that was so stunning
was these woolly mammoths that had been
literally knocked over by an impact with
broken legs and that died on the spot do
you have those images I do that was
actually a mastodon Mastodon I'm sorry
yeah yeah I want to see those so let's
go to the scablands first so we can show
the audience on YouTube which is by the
way only about 10% of the people that
watch this so if you're listening to
this go check out the
scablands on on google and you could see
this describe it to us randall well here
where this is textbook scab land right
here let's see what this is probably
Rock Lake or Spragg Lake into Cheney
Palouse scablands yeah you see the
potholes there that's a sign of
turbulence extreme turbulence within the
water Col king is then is what the
process is called where you get it's so
turbulent and it actually produces
vortexes high-intensity vortex motion in
the water it'll pick up sediment and
then it can drill its way right into the
into the bedrock going down there that's
Palouse Falls which was it it's a that's
an under fit waterfall because what you
have to realize is that at the peak of
the flooding this entire scene was
submerged below water and the cataract
here is an extinct feature and the flow
over here was thousands of times greater
than the present Palouse River that you
see right there we've got a lot of great
pictures up on the Geo cosmic Rex web
site and some awesome video clips
I'm serious you know cosmic Rex
rexxx okay and now you were saying wreak
like a car wreck well that's it's a play
on words
okay oh yeah we are talking about that
okay but yeah we got some great drone
footage on there did we show that last
time I was believe we did the light of
definitely showed a bit of end in the
Camas Prairie ripples did we show
potholes cataract yeah there yeah this
this whole scab landing is literally
fascinated me since 1970 and and like
Malcolm and I think that summer of 1970
traveling out some of these landscapes
was yeah here we go is the drone footage
Wow yeah and and let's see be ready to
pause if we need to here
is this the beginning because at the
beginning we have a Google Earth image
you can get a sense of what we're
looking at here go back to the beginning
right at the very beginning let's see if
it starts off with their drones oh it
starts off with the drone okay there
should be another one that actually
that's okay this is pretty cool yeah
this is this is these are 400 foot
cliffs this was a recessional cataract
very similar to dry falls the water was
pouring coming from behind our view here
where is this specifically if anybody
wanted to go watch this or look at this
area oh the actual area this is an
Eastern Washington this is this is an
eastern rim of Quinte base and it's
called it's right along just if you can
see up there where those cliffs are in
the middle distance right below there is
the Columbia River and this is just
north of Wenatchee Wisconsin grew up
Wisconsin Washington so basically what
we had here was a you know plucking
quarrying as the water poured over this
Ridge this is the Babcock Ridge and
behind us as the Quincy base and which
served as a temporary holding pond and
let's see is the is the drone comes
around I'm looking for the word the team
Oh
keep going to zoom in a little bit more
there Jamie I think we did shows you can
see you guys down there in the ground
right
yeah we're then there somewhere lost in
the vastness of the yeah now I remember
we did show this yeah what about those
images the the mastodons let's look at
those and then let's get out of here
okay for that you have to go to the
world of the pleistocene which I just
should have given you that sounds like a
music park yeah the world of the places
could be over there some dudes with
animal skins on well maybe if they
succeed in you know cloning some of
those frozen animals up there maybe
right what yeah I don't know how
plausible it is but that seems like a
terrible idea the lost world well that's
one of the big concerns about climate
change right that we're going to really
some diseases that we don't have an
immune system for yeah
go to slide 78 this is a good example of
by the way who is more thoroughly
documented than Randall Carlson Jesus
Christ man go to slide 6220 to 50 plus
years of woman walk in the channel
scablands yeah this this is a bone
deposit and what happens is that in the
particularly warm years when the the
permafrost around the rivers collapses
it exposes these huge deposits of Bones
which have been buried in the permafrost
this is you know when I look at stuff
like this this is I is why I say there
had to be another mechanisms of
extinction besides human hunting because
this pile yeah because it possible that
this I mean it's not necessarily at the
bottom of a cliff right because you know
that they pushed a lot of them off
cliffs and no no this this is stuff that
when the the river floods it erodes the
banks and then this stuff falls out of
the river banks right so it's it's been
locked into the permafrost for however
many thousands of years and it seems
like there's interestingly two peaks of
dates that one right around 13,000 and
the other one around 36,000 that that
the that they that the fossilized
remains are dating to which could point
to a potentially that there was some
sort of an impact back then as well or
something else no I I don't know I don't
have an opinion on there by having all
these together I mean has it been
theorized that perhaps this was a
there's not a cliff near this right yeah
just off the to the right there's you
see there is a cliff we're at the bottom
of a cliff right here that is the
actually it's a river bank so so just
you know that that was a hunting method
these two stormed them off the side of
cliffs and they never they literally
couldn't even eat all of them like head
smashed yeah yeah they would run so many
I'm off cliffs yeah but but here's the
thing here's the thing when you look at
it the the more these mortality events
of modern animals even like looking at
elephants that perish during some of the
severe droughts in the 80s in Africa
taphonomic studies show that it doesn't
take three four or five years before
the the remains have completely
disappeared mmm
in order to preserve a fossil that has
to be rapidly removed from any kind of
forces oxidation or scavenger or
anything that would consume it see this
stuff has been again it's been frozen in
the permafrost for for however many
years ten or twelve or fifteen thousand
years so it was likely covered in an
event covered in an event yes now what
there was one that I really wanted you
to get to that was a mastodon that had
been literally knocked over and had
broken legs yeah that would be we could
look very quickly at slide 92 this is
one of the more interesting anomalous
events this was the the flash-frozen
woolly mammoth go to the go to slide 93
it's a much clearer yeah this was a
mammoth six ton mammoth that was again
one of these River collapses the banks
collapsed during a warm spring and
exposed this remains of a wooly mammoth
with soft tissue preserved contents of
the food and its stomach undigested
actually a mouthful of food the hips of
the mammoth were were both broken as if
he was thrown back on his haunches very
violently he had an erect penis which
suggests to that he was suffocated was
he he was a freak or he was a freak
Michael laughs it out that the Wolves
ate the flesh off the skull that's why
it's it's buried like that you'll see
the front left forelimb
there you see the bottom there left
right at the centre of the screen that's
his back leg oh wow did you see right
there the interesting thing about this
is the you know the the rapidity of
climate change that's implied by being
able to freeze the six ton mammoth
because the contents of his stomach
according to the studies had not really
been putrified yet which implies that
the entire carcass had been frozen
through and through probably in less
than ten hours well I could see the
Iceman that's you know that's what
happened to him that's exactly what
happened to him yes yeah interesting
point and that would be a subject that
we should talk about what fell in
between a crevasse in a glacier correct
yeah it probably got rapidly buried
under the under the snow and the ice and
that's how he ended every night
preserved yeah overnight exactly the
next slide actually shows a
reconstruction of the of the in in this
in a museum in Russia showing what the
the mammoth the circumstances under
which he was found if you go to there's
a sidebar on duty to show you how
science changes rather slowly sometimes
it was a decade before they found out he
was murdered because they found arrow
point in his scapula here they cut his
bone Annie had defensive wounds on his
hands and arms so he'd gotten in a fight
and he had other people's blood on his
hand so he gave as good as he got and
lost a fight so he was murdered Wow and
that that took with all that careful
observation in laboratories of ten years
before that came out yeah so sometimes
this stuff has to just take a while so
if I can try to find some common ground
with before we sign off with Graham you
know your you know your book you have
this really great sentence that I quote
this it would mean at least that some
yet unknown and identified people
somewhere in the world had already
mastered all the arts and attributes of
a high civilization more than 12,000
years ago and sent out emissaries around
the world okay I think that's is
entirely possible cognitively for sure
and you know I would do it for me but
you know the boats that they sent the
emissaries out on the wood carbon-14
dated and some specific examples of high
arts and attributes of high civilization
so if it's not metal and writing then
you know whatever it is I would change
my mind absolutely that's good to hear
Michael and I I think as the as the
research continues in this area for the
last few years having been very much an
outsider I have felt that the evidence
is moving in a direction that is helpful
to the argument that I'm
I hope it'll continue to be that way I
hope the evidence that you're looking
for will will come out I'm trying to
like I say my role is a reporter and I'm
trying to be a reporter for the
alternative sides of things but to do so
to do so in an effective and and and
hopefully third there's a good argument
in the history of science to be made for
the role of outsiders I mean complete
Outsiders to come in and shake things up
I mean Freeman Dyson is an example you
know totally self-taught autodidact I
called you an autodidact absolutely and
they can make and if nothing else they
push people to really figure out what it
is they believe and why because
otherwise no one's going to challenge
them Harlen Bretz is a good example of
that you know a high school teacher
right
how about Randall Carlson well Liz you
still want to look at this real quick
mastodons I got it right here he could
go for days what I love about Randall he
never gets tired of this stuff if you
could bottle your enthusiasm it'd be an
awesome pill well maybe we can talk
about yeah all right we're gonna we're
gonna look at this this Mastodon here
125 125 yeah so this is a Mastodon that
was dug up in a pit years ago excavation
showed that the bones were lying on and
in a layer of limey clay or marl about 1
foot in thickness when they're meant to
do when it gets up there and it goes on
to see the skeleton proved to be badly
disturbed in the bones crushed and
broken as an example of the amount of
disturbance one of the ribs lay beneath
one of the tusks while another was
thrust through an aperture in the pelvis
a shoulder blade rested to the right of
the skull and one of the large neck
vertebrae was found about ten feet from
the skull near a portion of the pelvis
in spite of the wide dislocation of the
parts the now this is where it really is
interesting the bones of one of the feet
remained intact and in place very
possibly in the spot where the animal
last stepped so in other words the foot
there was a foot still embedded in the
soft material where he was apparently
stepping at the time whatever happened
to him
and this is all the same time period as
the other Macedon we don't have dating
on this but it likely was at the very
end probably writing at Younger Dryas
window because of the amount of sediment
over it go to the next slide Jaime and
we'll see 1:26 we can get a better so
this thing theoretically at least was
blown back yeah go to there we go there
you can see one of the femurs that's
been busted squarely across they go on
to say that even the largest of the
bones such as the thigh bones were
broken squarely across in places
indicating that some considerable force
had been exerted upon them any
conclusion as to an agency powerful
enough to cause such destruction must be
highly speculative so basically what
you're seeing here is a Mastodon that
got smashed into into the ground Wow
the the forces there were strong
powerful shear forces that would have
literally separated his leg from the
foot that's still in immersed into the
into the ground so I mean there are many
examples of this and the last slide
we're gonna show if you go back this I
promise once went digging with Jack
Horner that paleontologist the dinosaur
digger and he he showed these debris
flow pile ups of dinosaur bones that had
been splintered and broken Wow and these
are huge just from the force of the
water and then piling up at the a of a
wall and so if we can do it to a
dinosaur Wow right yeah 85 85 is an
interesting slide because what it shows
is the London ivory docks which over a
period of about two centuries this was
this was mammoth ivory that's being dug
out of the Siberian permafrost that's
just a drawing oh that's just a drawing
yeah with that like that's what it
looked like
19th century scene showing the ivory
floor of the London Docks covered by
thousands of mammoth tusks and this went
on year after year after year after year
for roughly two
centuries there is so much of that
mammoth ivory by the way that they use
it to make knife handles so they
actually have a knife handle you that I
that was made out of mammoth ivory yeah
and still to this day not only is it
legal but it's common to use mammoth
ivory for different kinds of things
there's so much of it well they're not
all dangered species because they're
it's kind of a loophole in this case so
what we have is tucks that are being
again dug out of the permafrost right so
how did they get there that becomes the
question right does it have anything to
do with human predation or was it a
natural catastrophe that somehow ended
up putting all these mammoths down and
burying them into permafrost that's the
question I want to raise well I think we
raised a lot of questions I think we we
got some pretty good answers I think we
had some great dialogue and I really
appreciate your time all three of you
guys and thank you to Malcolm and thank
you to mark and thank you to young Jaime
oh thanks for hosting my pleasure thank
you can I do a quick shout out shout it
out I want to thank Brad Young Cameron
Wiltshire my brother Rowan my wife Julie
for helping all make this possible I
also want to have people go to the Geo
cosmic Rex website and the sacred
geometry international website for a lot
more of this kind of stuff then I'm
going to thank my beloved partner and
wife Santha whose shared every adventure
with me for the last quarter of a
century we've climbed the Great Pyramid
together we've been at the bottom of the
ocean together and I wouldn't be doing
any of this stuff if it weren't for that
wonderful woman behind me Michael
Shermer who you want to thank oh thank
my wife Jennifer my little boy Vinny and
my agent my light no no no but sceptic
calm and my partner Pat who you know
keeps the show running when I'm running
around doing things like this all right
I'm Joe Rogan Joe I speak all over the
world and whether it's South Africa or
whether it's Japan or whether it's
Britain or whether it's the United
States or whether it's Croatia people
come up to me and they say Joe Rogan son
yeah well thank you I appreciate that
interesting guess well you're one of
them dude that all you guys are thank
you so much all right we'll see you guys
soon thank you fine so long
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]